Salut, ici Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, j'espère que vous allez bien. Comme promis cette semaine, je reçois un invité politique de premier plan en la personne de Georges-Louis Bouchez, président du Mouvement Réformateur.
Fait rare qui mérite d'être souligné,
c'est lui et son équipe qui ont émis le souhait de participer au podcast. J'ai reçu jusqu'à présent quatre personnalités politiques dans Septante Minutes Avec, c'est une minorité parmi tous les invités que j'ai pu recevoir,
deux hommes et deux femmes, mais c'est vrai que le MR n'avait jamais encore été représenté dans Septante Minutes Avec.
C'est maintenant chose faite. J'ai choisi de recevoir Georges-Louis Bouchez parce que j'estime qu'il se passe quelque chose au MR en sa présidence, à savoir une ligne claire, radicale et qui s'affirme à droite du spectre politique belge.
Et j'estime que c'est intéressant d'observer ce changement et d'en discuter avec lui. On commence par évoquer des sujets d'actualité et puis on termine par des questions qui concernent son parti et son style.
Dernier détail important, Georges-Louis et moi avions les deux mêmes micros réglés de la même manière, mais, comme vous allez pouvoir l'observer, il y a eu un petit souci de son côté, le son sature assez régulièrement.
Je pense que ça reste écoutable, mais je vous présente toutes mes excuses pour ça. C'est la première fois que ça se produit et c'est ma responsabilité.
J'avais pas anticipé que mon invité parlerait aussi fort. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir de recevoir Georges-Louis Bouchez.
Georges-Louis, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes, pour les rares qui ne vous connaissent pas encore, le président du Mouvement Réformateur. Plaisir de vous recevoir, en particulier, donc aujourd'hui, le jour de votre anniversaire, c'était même pas prévu, mais voilà.
Exact, ouais.
Et donc je vais être non pas particulièrement gentil avec vous, mais je vais en tout cas vous faire un petit cadeau.
Je vous permets de choisir le sujet avec lequel on va démarrer. Qu'est-ce que vous préférez entre
parler de la ligne politique du Mouvement Réformateur, parler du nucléaire, qui est un sujet qui vous anime beaucoup en ce moment, parler de la situation avec les réfugiés ukrainiens actuellement.
Par quoi allons-nous commencer ?
Ah, mais ça dépend, en fait. On abordera tous les sujets ou… ?
Oui, oui, oui. C'est pas un choix qui éliminera les autres.
C'est pas un choix qui élimine les autres. Ah ben alors, écoutez, peut-être l'accueil,
Très bien
des réfugiés ukrainiens, puisque c'est d'actualité et j'ai peut-être moins eu l'occasion de m'exprimer là-dessus que sur les deux autres.
OK, très bien, bien annoncé alors. Je rappelle qu'il y a une situation comparable à la crise des réfugiés en Syrie.
De nombreux Ukrainiens, Ukrainiennes traversent les frontières et arrivent en Pologne, en Allemagne et même jusqu'en Belgique.
Et beaucoup se questionnent vis-à-vis de la différence de traitement que connaissent les réfugiés ukrainiens par rapport aux réfugiés du Moyen-Orient, réfugiés syriens notamment, il y a quelques années.
Il était plutôt question de les enfermer dans des parcs, de les entasser, les regarder galérer. Alors qu'aujourd'hui, on parle plutôt de faire des hashtags, je ne sais plus, place dispo, #PlaceDispo pour les accueillir chez nous.
Alors qu'il y a, je pense que c'était il y a environ sept ans, on parlait plutôt de visites domiciliaires pour justement retrouver les réfugiés, essayer de voir s'ils étaient bien légalement présents sur notre territoire.
Qu'est-ce qui explique cette différence de traitement récemment ?
Alors, déjà, y a un préalable par rapport à ce que vous dites, c'est que c'est inexact, ce qui était indiqué sur les réfugiés afghans.
Donc le but n'était pas du tout de les entasser dans des parcs. En Belgique, la règle a toujours été la même. Quand vous venez sur le territoire, vous devez introduire une demande de régularisation
ou faire une demande pour avoir le statut de réfugié.
Et c'est ce qui s'est passé. Donc, les personnes qui venaient d'Afghanistan rendraient une demande pour avoir l'asile et donc le statut de réfugié.
Et à 98 % des cas, que ce soit pour les Syriens ou pour les Afghans, ils avaient leur statut de réfugié. Pendant le temps de la procédure, ils reçoivent un logement,
ils ont des aides matérielles pour pouvoir subvenir à leurs besoins.
Et après, lorsqu'ils ont le statut de réfugié, eh bien, ils sont comme n'importe quel citoyen résidant, en tout cas en Belgique, avec les mêmes droits, la possibilité de travailler, la possibilité de pouvoir,
aller au CPAS en cas de nécessité, d'avoir un logement social, etc., etc.
Et donc, l'histoire des parcs, un, c'était des gens qui soit n'avaient pas introduit de demande de régularisation, qu'on soit bien clair, parce qu'il y a des gens qui voulaient aller en Angleterre et selon les règlements européens,
si vous êtes identifié dans un pays européen avant
d'aller dans un autre, vous allez être renvoyé dans le premier pays européen dans lequel vous avez été identifié.
Et beaucoup avaient la volonté d'aller en Angleterre. D'autres avaient reçu des ordres de quitter le territoire, qui n'étaient pas respectés, parce que c'est pas parce que quelqu'un dit qu'il vient d'Afghanistan ou de Syrie qu'il en vient réellement.
Et donc il y a des enquêtes qui sont menées pour déterminer. Et sur la question des visites domiciliaires, c'était uniquement parce que lorsque vous introduisez une demande de régularisation, vous devez mettre une adresse de référence.
Et quand cette demande de régularisation est refusée, eh bien, le bourgmestre a trois mois pour vérifier si la personne a bien quitté le territoire.
Et jusqu'à présent, qu'est-ce qui se passait ? Les policiers allaient devant l'adresse qui avait été renseignée et ne pouvaient pas rentrer à l'intérieur pour vérifier.
Et les visites domiciliaires visaient simplement à pouvoir faire une visite à l'intérieur, mais certainement pas pour poursuivre les gens qui allaient chercher des personnes au parc Maximilien, puisqu'on n'avait même pas leur adresse.
De toute façon, on n'aurait même pas su, même si on l'avait voulu et on ne l'a pas voulu. Premier élément. Deuxième élément sur les Ukrainiens.
Il y a deux différences majeures entre les Ukrainiens et d'autres migrants.
La première différence, c'est qu'avant la guerre, il y avait déjà un accord entre l'Ukraine et l'Union européenne qui permettait à des ressortissants ukrainiens de plus ou moins avoir les mêmes droits que des citoyens européens.
C'est-à-dire qu'un Ukrainien pouvait venir en Belgique, par exemple, pour trois mois, sans visa, sans aucune procédure. Et au bout de trois mois, la même procédure s'appliquait que s'il était italien ou français.
Première différence. Deuxième différence, lorsqu'il y a un pays qui est en guerre, en général, entre 80 et 90 % des déplacements de population se font dans les pays limitrophes.
Il se fait que cette fois-ci, les pays limitrophes, c'est l'Europe, ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas quand c'est l'Afghanistan ou la Syrie.
Et donc, ces deux éléments nous conduisent à effectivement mener des politiques qui sont spécifiques à ce cas.
Pourquoi ? Parce que, un, on sait qu'on va accueillir beaucoup plus de gens naturellement, puisque, ben, si vous montez dans un train en Pologne, vous pouvez très vite vous retrouver en Belgique.
Et deuxième élément, je le disais,
même sans prendre de dispositions particulières, les Ukrainiens pourraient venir en Belgique et rester
au minimum trois mois sans aucune condition, sans aucun contrôle préalable, ce qui n'est pas le cas pour des Afghans ou des Syriens, par exemple.
Ça, c'est en raison des accords européens et du fait que les Européens ont une tendance à offrir des droits semblables à des pays qui ne sont pas membres de l'Union, mais qui en sont limitrophes.
Ça peut, par exemple, être le cas de la Norvège aussi, où on a des accords privilégiés avec la Norvège.
Oui. Le contexte politique a évidemment évolué entre-temps avec les élections qu'on a connues ici en Belgique, où on a vu une forte montée, notamment au nord du pays,
du vote à l'extrême droite, du vote nationaliste, du vote, on peut le dire, xénophobe.
Est-ce que ça change la donne ? Est-ce que, de par ce vote de, finalement, de la population belge,
la réponse des représentants, la réponse, que ce soit du Parlement flamand ou la Chambre des représentants au niveau fédéral,
est influencée, va avoir une réponse différente vu que le contexte des élections a évolué entre-temps ?
Mais en fait, quand on dit : « Ça a évolué entre-temps », en fait, c'est pas nécessairement le résultat d'une élection.
C'est un phénomène sociétal qui vit depuis des années. C'est que y a un besoin de justice dans notre société.
Et donc il faut quand même arrêter de considérer que toute réflexion qui vise à amener de la justice soit une réflexion raciste ou xénophobe. Mais-
Ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit
Non, non, c'est pas ce que vous, vous dites, mais je parle en général.
Je dis juste que le problème, c'est que y a une série de situations qui n'ont pas été prises en charge par les partis traditionnels et donc ça a donné des boulevards à des partis extrémistes.
Mais il était quand même pas normal que dans un pays, vous puissiez, par exemple, au nom du regroupement familial, regrouper toute une famille sans limite alors que vous n'avez pas de conditions de revenus.
Vous savez, à un moment, il faut maintenir l'équilibre entre la générosité et l'équilibre des comptes publics. Et donc, à ce titre-là, c'est logique d'avoir des éléments de contrôle, qu'on puisse déterminer des conditions de revenus.
Parce que si vous ne faites pas ça, alors ce que vous mettez en péril, c'est la sécurité sociale. Donc, pour être tout à fait clair avec vous, on a aussi fait un grand mélange entre la migration et le fait d'être un réfugié.
Donc la migration, celle-là doit être contrôlée, limitée, il faut des règles, des conditions de revenus. Le statut de réfugié, lui, n'a jamais été limité.
Et donc on a souvent fait la confusion de dire : « Oui, mais ce sont des gens qui fuient un pays d'origine dans lesquels ils subissent des souffrances.
» On va être très clair, il faut distinguer le risque que l'on court pour sa vie, ça, c'est le statut de réfugié, et le fait de fuir un pays où on vit moins bien que chez nous.
Mais si vous faites la liste des pays dans lesquels on vit moins bien que chez nous, vous avez entre 150 et 180 pays dans le monde.
Et vous ne pouvez pas accueillir tout le monde.
On parlait précédemment de l'Ukraine, de la Syrie, donc il n'était pas question de parler de migration-
Oui, mais la question que vous me posiez : « Est-ce que ça a changé le positionnement, les résultats électoraux ?
» Moi, je dis depuis, de façon plus globale, la question de la migration n'a pas été prise en charge pendant de très nombreuses années.
On a vu le phénomène grimper dans les années 90. Et puis, à un moment donné, malheureusement,
comme les partis traditionnels, il était impossible de parler de certaines choses, il était pas possible de limiter l'immigration, on pouvait pas parler de l'intégration.
On se souvient de cette fameuse phrase, hein, que l'intégration est un échec en Belgique, qui avait soulevé une très grande polémique au début des années 2000.
Aujourd'hui, c'est devenu assez usuel de pouvoir faire ce constat. Donc à force d'ignorer des réalités vécues par beaucoup de gens, eh bien, on en arrive à ce résultat.
Et donc, c'est pas le vote vis-à-vis des partis extrémistes qui, à un moment donné, influence. C'est qu'il est la manifestation de quelque chose qui vit dans la société.
Et donc c'est quelque chose qui doit être réglé. Parce que quand vous dites : « C'est des Syriens », vous savez, sur les années 2015, 2016, 2017, on nous a dit : « Ah, c'est que des Syriens et des Afghans ».
C'est pas vrai. Y avait, dans toute une partie de ces personnes, on avait des personnes qui venaient d'autres pays, qui fuyaient des conditions de vie qui étaient des conditions de vie difficiles.
Mais malheureusement, et ça, il faut l'admettre aussi, on ne peut pas prendre en charge la population de, je l'ai dit, près de 180 pays dans le monde où on vit moins bien qu'en Belgique. Ça doit d'ailleurs
faire réfléchir une série de Belges qui se plaignent au quotidien. Ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas beaucoup de réformes à mener dans notre pays, mais il faut quand même bien considérer qu'on fait partie d'un top 10, voire d'un top 20,
des pays où il fait le mieux vivre dans le monde.
Et donc ça, c'est quand même aussi un point qui est intéressant à rappeler. Mais pour être tout à fait complet sur ce sujet,
durant les dernières années, on avait, par exemple, beaucoup de populations qui venaient du Nigeria.
Le Nigeria est un pays où il fait moins bon vivre qu'en Belgique, ça, c'est un fait, mais le Nigeria n'était pas un pays d'où ils fuyaient,
pour sauver leur vie, ou en tout cas pas au sens entendu par les conventions internationales qui déterminent le statut de réfugié.
Et donc, dans ce cas, si ces personnes ne remplissaient pas les conditions, elles devaient être renvoyées dans leur pays.
Oui.
là où j'essaye de vous amener, et je pense que vous l'avez peut-être deviné, c'est
précisément le fait que quand on parle de population musulmane, il y a le spectre de l'extrême droite qui survole tout cela et qui amène vers des théories complotistes style grand remplacement, style,
un espèce d'adéquation, une espèce d'équivalence entre musulmans et islamisme radical,
qui, voilà, qui tendrait à amener une certaine réticence, une certaine tension dans la population vis-à-vis de populations plutôt du type issues du Moyen-Orient,
voilà, qui ne serait pas du tout présent quand on parle de réfugiés ukrainiens.
Vous n'êtes pas sensible à ces idées, je le vois à votre visage.
Non, mais dans le sens où,
le problème, c'est qu'on fait un grand melting pot de tout.
C'est-à-dire que, de un, tout de suite, on essaie de chercher la différence de traitement entre les Afghans, les Syriens d'un côté, les Ukrainiens de l'autre.
J'ai expliqué, y a des éléments qui sont hyper rationnels. De deux,
y a quand même un point qui est dérangeant, c'est que par principe, il y a une série de réalités qu'on ne veut pas voir parce qu'on dit : « Ça, c'est ce que dit l'extrême droite.
» Donc la théorie du grand remplacement, par exemple. La théorie du grand remplacement, moi, je n'y adhère pas à partir du moment où il n'y a pas un grand complot mondial de remplacer une population par une autre.
Ça, non. Mais pourquoi elle a un certain succès dans la population ? Parce qu'aujourd'hui,
dans certains quartiers,
il y a des gens qui n'adhèrent pas à l'idée du grand remplacement,
mais qui se disent : « Mais finalement, on est dans une inversion en termes, par exemple, d'adhésion religieuse, où on est passé d'un quartier où il y avait des laïcs et des chrétiens,
puis du jour au lendemain, il y a une majorité de musulmans,
ou des personnes d'origine étrangère, voire de nationalité étrangère dans certains cas.
» Est-ce que c'est un problème en soi ? Non. Mais est-ce que ça n'engendre pas des modifications du comportement du tissu social ?
Bien sûr que oui. Est-ce que ces changements de comportement doivent être pris en compte par le politique dans l'organisation de l'espace public, dans l'organisation de la société ?
Oui. Et donc, comme on l'a pas fait, comme on a fermé les yeux, eh ben aujourd'hui, il y a une série de personnes qui, je crois, à tort, se sentent menacées par rapport à leur culture, par rapport à leurs valeurs.
Mais si de l'autre côté, on n'apporte pas des réponses pour montrer que c'est un vrai vivre ensemble que l'on construit et non pas des gens qui vivent les uns à côté des autres,
alors vous allez avoir des problèmes et vous allez permettre à l'extrême droite de faire florès.
Et moi, ce que je ne supporte plus, c'est qu'on ne veut pas regarder une série de réalités en face. Aujourd'hui, pourquoi la cohésion sociale ne marche pas à Bruxelles ?
Parce qu'il y a pas assez de mixité dans les quartiers. Pourquoi à un moment donné, on a des difficultés ?
Parce qu'on a considéré que les populations d'origine étrangère devaient toutes habiter dans les mêmes quartiers, dans lesquels on allait mettre une maison de quartier, dans lesquels on allait subventionner des assos.
On allait mettre une table de ping-pong. Je pense que Bruxelles est une des villes où il y a le plus de tables de ping-pong au monde, parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a des gosses qui gueulent,
on leur met une table de ping-pong et on leur fait un mini-foot.
D'ailleurs, pourquoi y a pas de maison de quartier à Woluwe ? Je trouve ça très bizarre. C'est déjà une drôle de conception de considérer, eux, ils ont besoin d'un petit jouet, on va leur donner un truc pour dire de--
alors que les vrais problèmes, c'est quoi ?
Les vrais problèmes, c'est l'emploi. Quand on nous dit qu'il y a plus de chômage à Molenbeek qu'ailleurs à cause de la discrimination, je suis désolé, je suis pas en train de nier la discrimination, mais regardez le niveau moyen de diplôme.
Le taux de chômage à Molenbeek est identique à celui de Colfontaine. À Colfontaine, il y a beaucoup moins de populations d'origine étrangère, mais ils ont le même niveau d'éducation et d'enseignement.
Et donc, à partir de là, il faudrait peut-être aller un peu plus loin que cette logique de dire : « Il y a la peur de l'islam, il y a la peur du musulman.
» Il se fait qu'aujourd'hui, effectivement, comme dans beaucoup de sociétés, les populations immigrées sont en général les plus précarisées.
Je dis pas toutes, mais quand on prend des statistiques moyennes. Pourquoi ? Ben parce que quand vous quittez un pays, en général, c'est parce que vous n'êtes pas parmi la classe dirigeante, hein, souvent.
Et donc, quand on arrive sur le territoire, on a des difficultés. Et si ces personnes sont confrontées à des situations de chômage, eh bien alors, cette précarité ne s'améliore pas.
On n'arrive pas à améliorer le niveau de vie. Mais pourquoi il y a du chômage ? Il y a pas que la discrimination, il faut arrêter.
Il y a un problème de qualité de l'enseignement qui ne permet pas à chacun d'avoir les mêmes outils. Puis après, donc, ça se poursuit dans la suite sur la diplomation.
La diplomation a une influence directe sur l'emploi, etc., etc. Et donc,
je pense qu'on doit quitter, je dis pas que c'est ce que vous faites hein, mais on doit quitter la vision victimaire et la vision selon laquelle
émettre n'importe quelle remarque, difficulté, problème par rapport à la migration, doit être tout le temps catégorisée comme un élément d'extrême droite.
Aujourd'hui, il faut se mettre à la place de certaines personnes qui ont vu leur quartier totalement changer en 30 ans. Alors, il faut pas juste leur renvoyer à la figure que si ça leur fait peur, ce sont des crétins et des racistes.
Il faut à un moment donné prendre ça en charge, dire : « Ben effectivement, comment on fait pour garder une cohésion dans ce quartier ?
Comment on fait économiquement pour que tout le monde puisse trouver un emploi ? Comment on fait au niveau de l'éducation ?
Comment on fait dans l'aménagement du territoire ? » Vous savez, aujourd'hui, parquer des gens selon une origine ou une confession religieuse dans le même quartier,
c'est pas du vivre ensemble hein, c'est pas du vivre ensemble que de dire : « Bon, à Molenbeek, on a tel type de population, à Woluwe, on a un autre type de population », parce qu'en fait, c'est par
le fait que les populations se mélangent qu'on peut faire augmenter aussi le niveau moyen sur un plan socioéconomique, par exemple.
On peut en discuter. Donc, pour revenir sur ce que vous disiez, donc vous prenez très clairement vos distances vis-à-vis de théories complotistes du style grand remplacement, mais simplement, vous expliquez que,
il peut y avoir une question de perception vis-à-vis de certains vécus, certains quartiers, qui peut permettre, voilà, un terreau, une compatibilité vers-
Vers certaines méfiances. Je vais être très clair avec vous. Si vous vivez à Laeken-
Mmh-mmh
depuis 40 ans, ben je suis désolé, à un moment donné, moi, je peux comprendre que quelqu'un qui vit à Laeken depuis 40 ans, quand il entend des théories comme celle du grand remplacement, il soit séduit.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Parce que si à un moment donné, on ne va pas lui expliquer et on n'aménage pas les choses, eh bien, la personne va aller vers
ce que lui ressent au quotidien, de dire : « Mais attendez, avant, il y avait une population qui était extrêmement homogène d'un côté, puis maintenant, on a une population très homogène, mais qui est issue de la diversité.
Donc, est-ce qu'à un moment donné, moi, j'ai encore ma place dans ce quartier ? Est-ce que ça pose pas de difficultés ?
» Et c'est là où je dis qu'on a raté le vivre ensemble. Parce que le vrai vivre ensemble, ça serait justement que personne n'ait peur l'un de l'autre.
Oui, donc on peut effectivement partager ce bilan, ce constat de vivre ensemble échoué à plusieurs niveaux.
Pour reprendre la question très spécifique de l'enseignement et de la mixité sociale au sein de l'école, alors, ça remonte à ma jeune adolescence, donc j'espère que je ne vais pas dire de bêtises, mais dans mes souvenirs,
la mixité sociale, c'était un grand projet de Marie Arena, au sein de sa réforme,
Du décret inscription.
Oui, décret inscription, qui a connu un succès tout relatif.
le souvenir que j'ai
C'est que l'opposition à cette réforme était principalement issue justement de quartiers plutôt bourgeois, qui étaient très agacés à l'idée de voir arriver dans leur école très catholique, très chrétienne, très bourgeoise, une population
jugée négativement, jugée, voilà, de quartier, vous disiez Molenbeek, Laeken, et cetera.
Donc ce refus de cette mixité sociale, il est à plusieurs niveaux, il est partagé, il est collectif.
Comment est-ce qu'on travaille culturellement à favoriser un accueil, une ouverture d'esprit vis-à-vis de cette mixité sociale ?
Mais déjà, dans un premier temps, on vise à faire en sorte que le niveau des écoles soit le même partout.
Et donc, la question à se poser, c'est : pourquoi vous avez un niveau d'enseignement moyen qui est plus faible dans certains quartiers que d'autres ?
Il est mauvais de manière générale en Belgique, selon les scores.
Alors, le niveau-- Non, alors justement, notre test PISA montre deux choses, c'est que nos bons élèves sont meilleurs que la moyenne des bons élèves ailleurs dans l'OCDE.
Mais nos élèves en difficulté sont plus en difficulté que ceux qui le sont au niveau OCDE. Et donc, on a en fait, le bilan de ça, c'est qu'on a un enseignement très inégalitaire.
Pourquoi il est très inégalitaire ? Parce que, et c'est pour ça qu'on était contre, au niveau du MR, le décret inscription,
parce que le décret inscription revient à dire qu'il y a effectivement des écoles de qualité et des écoles de deuxième catégorie, pour rester poli.
Et donc, la difficulté de cet élément, c'est que ce qu'avait prévu Marie Arena du premier entré, premier servi,
tenait à dire, et c'est ça la contestation surtout, tenait à clicher finalement qu'il y avait des bonnes et des mauvaises écoles.
Donc elle a renforcé cette idée-là et que donc il fallait que j'arrive premier pour être sûr d'être dans la bonne école.
Et tant pis, s'il y a plus de place pour les autres, ben les autres, ils iront dans les écoles de deuxième, troisième, voire quatrième catégorie.
C'est ça qui pose problème. Et donc vous allez me dire : « Mais comment on fait pour améliorer le niveau moyen de l'école ?
» Alors là, je crois qu'il y a deux éléments.
Un, quand on dit qu'il y a des bonnes et des mauvaises écoles, moi, j'y crois pas des masses, dans le sens où je dis y a pas des profs--
tous les profs excellents ne se retrouvent pas dans les collèges jésuites et les mauvais profs dans les écoles communales de quartier, à discrimination positive.
Ça, ça n'est pas vrai. Ça n'est pas vrai. La différence, c'est quoi ? Ben, c'est en fait qu'ils se retrouvent face à des élèves qui sont plus en prédisposition pour participer à un phénomène d'enseignement.
C'est-à-dire que quand vous venez d'un milieu socioculturel plus élevé, vous êtes déjà habitué aux livres, que vos parents vous aident pour faire vos devoirs.
C'est quand même plus simple que quand vous êtes dans une famille nombreuse où on n'a pas l'occasion, le temps, la possibilité ou autre, ou parfois les capacités financières, voire même les connaissances culturelles.
Si vous-même, vous ne maîtrisez pas la langue du pays, c'est pas très simple pour aider les gamins à faire les devoirs.
Et donc, en réalité,
c'est pas le prof qui est différent. C'est comme au football. C'est quand même toujours plus simple d'être le coach du Paris Saint-Germain, même si pas trop en ce moment, ou du Real Madrid et de Barcelone ou de Manchester City,
parce que vous savez que vous avez quatre bons joueurs par poste, que d'être le coach de Saint-Trond ou quand vous en avez un bon sur les 11, ben vous êtes déjà content et vous espérez qu'il se blesse pas.
Ici, c'est exactement la même chose en matière d'enseignement. Vous vous retrouvez face à une classe où, naturellement, vous avez d'un côté des gens qui ont plus
de prédispositions, non pas naturelles, mais socioculturelles, pour dire, d'être réceptifs à ce que vous allez faire et à ce que vous allez enseigner.
Donc ça, c'est le premier aspect. Donc, comment on corrige ça ? En fait, au niveau de l'enseignement de la Belgique francophone, on dépense plus d'argent que la plupart des autres en matière d'enseignement.
Mais on en dépense beaucoup moins en termes d'encadrement. L'encadrement, c'est quoi ? C'est les devoirs après les cours. C'est,
le fait de voir qu'un élève est en train de décrocher, on va lui réexpliquer en petit groupe. C'est l'accompagner,
au sens strict, de façon plus individualisée, donc ce que font des écoles privées ou des cours de remédiation comme Cogito,
hein, qui font Flores,
où des élèves essaient de faire de la remédiation par ce biais-là.
Mais il faut avoir de l'argent, il faut avoir un suivi. Et donc ce qu'il faut, c'est ça. Faut même arrêter avec la discrimination positive où on rajoute du pognon à mort pour avoir des classes de 15 et avoir l'ordinateur dernier cri.
On a bien vu que ça ne sert à rien. Ça sert strictement à rien. Il faut un suivi et vous pouvez même travailler par groupes de 20 ou 25 par classe, ça ne changera pas.
Il faut, dans ce groupe de 20 à 25, étudier vos élèves qui tirent vers le haut, très bien. Et puis tous les autres qui, à un moment donné, ont besoin de remédiation spécifique après les heures de cours et d'un accompagnement.
Parce que aujourd'hui, vous renvoyez des enfants à la maison, qui ne pourront pas avoir le soutien dont on a besoin pour dire de.
Et donc c'est l'école qui doit l'offrir. Et moi, je vais même encore aller un cran plus loin, je termine par là.
Je sais que c'est une proposition qui peut en faire criser certains, mais c'est en partie une tradition française du début du 20ème, fin du 19ème.
Il y avait ce qu'on appelait les internats. Et moi, je suis plutôt en faveur, parce qu'aujourd'hui, le système belge, il est un peu dingue.
Le système belge, c'est soit vous êtes un parent, vous avez la garde complète de vos gosses et vous faites un peu ce que vous voulez, soit on va vous retirer la garde, mais là, ça veut dire que vous avez été hyper loin.
Y a pas la vision intermédiaire où à un moment donné, quand on voit que des parents sont en difficulté,
qu'ils n'ont pas les outils, parfois, pour justement suivre un parcours scolaire, on puisse se dire : « Ben cinq jours de la semaine, vous allez en internat.
On prend tout en charge, l'alimentation saine, le sport, les cours, tout ce qu'il y a après les cours et vous rentrez dans votre famille le week-end.
Y a vraiment pas de problème à ça.
» Alors, comment on le ferait ? Ben, ça doit toujours rester sur une base volontaire, mais on pourrait identifier des élèves qui sont peut-être en décrochage
et où on se dit : « Pour cette famille-là, on pourrait peut-être les aider, les décharger de cette façon-là.
» Parce qu'aujourd'hui, en réalité, à force de se donner bonne conscience, on abandonne des milliers d'enfants. Y a aujourd'hui des milliers d'enfants qui ont la capacité d'avoir,
certaines trajectoires professionnelles et de parcours académiques qui ne le font pas
Parce que, voilà, il y a des difficultés au niveau familial qui leur permettent pas d'aller plus haut.
Et ça, c'est le rôle de l'État. Parce que, et je suis profondément libéral, je pense que je le dis assez souvent, le libéralisme a comme premier élément le fait de l'égalité des chances.
Et aujourd'hui, l'égalité des chances n'est pas garantie en raison de cet élément-là. On a un système d'enseignement unique pour des élèves qui sont avec des situations différenciées.
Donc, je pense pas qu'on sait faire un système par étudiant, mais on sait au moins avoir, je vous l'ai dit, le système traditionnel pour une grande masse, un système au milieu où on a un peu plus d'encadrement après les heures de cours.
Et je pense qu'on peut aller jusqu'au système d'internat qui permet à des familles de pouvoir être suppléées face à certaines difficultés de suivi.
Alors, énormément de choses qui ont été dites là-dedans. On va, tout doucement, évidemment, passer-
J'essaie de faire des propositions hein, donc.
On va tout doucement glisser vers d'autres sujets comme le nucléaire, mais je vais revenir sur plusieurs points que vous avez évoqués.
Notamment, donc, la question de base qui était la question de la mixité sociale dans les enseignements.
En quoi est-ce que cette mesure de favoriser l'enseignement, disons, après les cours ou carrément en internat, en quoi est-ce que ça favorise, puisque on constate que les
difficultés, les profils en décrochage scolaire viennent plutôt de certains profils socioéconomiques ?
En quoi est-ce que dire : « Bon ben, on va tous les conseiller de les envoyer dans des internats », en quoi est-ce que ça favorise la mixité sociale, une solution comme ça ?
Bah, alors, on va être clair, la mixité sociale en tant que telle
n'est pas une fin en soi. La mixité sociale doit être un point d'arrivée qui démontre que, justement, on est dans une société qui est fluide, où les gens se côtoient, où,
y a pas de frein a priori, quelle que soit votre couleur de peau, votre religion, votre origine.
Et donc les mesures proposées ici ne sont pas celles qui favoriseraient en effet immédiat
la mixité, mais c'est celles qui permettraient le fait pour certains enfants de se hisser dans certains parcours auxquels ils n'ont pas accès aujourd'hui et qui débouchera à la fin sur la mixité sociale.
Parce que la mixité sociale dans les écoles, vous savez, les gens, ils choisissent en général une école selon leur lieu de travail ou leur lieu de vie.
Et donc, aujourd'hui, vous pouvez dire à quelqu'un qui vit à Molenbeek : « Grâce au tirage au sort », à l'époque, on a passé même par le tirage au sort.
Après Marie Arena, on a eu Dupont, etc. « Grâce au tirage au sort, tu vas aller à Saint-Michel. » Mais ça changera pas grand-chose, en fait.
Parce que, en plus, c'est des complexités pour la famille, parce qu'en général, on choisit l'école la plus proche par rapport au quartier.
Et donc, ce que je dis, c'est que on doit véritablement accompagner l'élève. Et le fait, à un moment donné, qu'on va niveler le niveau par le haut va naturellement renforcer la mixité sociale.
Pourquoi ? Bah parce que plus haut niveau d'études, meilleure formation veut dire meilleur emploi à la fin. Meilleur emploi, beh, permet justement plus de mobilité dans l'achat du logement d'habitation.
Donc, les gens vont commencer à se mélanger parce qu'il y a un progrès socioéconomique. Aujourd'hui, il faut être très clair.
Ce qui se passe, et je le disais tout à l'heure, c'est que les populations immigrées sont en général les plus précarisées sur le plan socioéconomique.
Je dis bien en général. Et donc, le problème de Molenbeek, c'est pas qu'il y ait une majorité de populations d'origine étrangère.
Le problème de Mo-- dans certains quartiers. Le problème de Molenbeek, c'est qu'il y a un taux de chômage beaucoup plus élevé qu'ailleurs.
C'est ça, le problème de Molenbeek. Et donc, d'ailleurs, c'est ce qui fait la différence entre Schaerbeek et Molenbeek.
Or, Schaerbeek est une commune où il y a aussi une grande densité de populations d'origine étrangère, mais on a énormément de commerces, de commerçants, d'activités économiques.
Et donc, posez-vous d'ailleurs la question de savoir pourquoi le PS n'a jamais eu le mayorat à Schaerbeek. Mais voilà.
Et donc, moi, je refuse de faire des liens un peu faciles, de dire : « Vous êtes étranger, donc comme vous êtes étranger, vous êtes chômeur.
Et en plus, si vous êtes chômeur et étranger, c'est sûr, vous votez Écolo ou PS. » Non, on voit bien que la réalité est beaucoup plus complexe.
Et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que moi, je suis très en colère contre le gouvernement bruxellois qui essaie toujours de résumer ça à, finalement, à une question essentialiste, hein, des individus.
On essaie de les essentialiser en disant : « Vous êtes jeunes, immigrés, donc vous allez être discriminés. » Donc, les mecs, ils baissent les bras avant même d'avoir commencé.
Alors que derrière, ben non, il faut s'attaquer de : pourquoi on a un niveau d'emploi qui est plus faible ici ? Pourquoi on a des jeunes, encore une fois à Molenbeek,
qui ont pas de boulot, alors qu'à 15 minutes en bus, à Zaventem, y a des demandes d'emploi qui sont pas pourvues ?
Ah, ils savent pas bien le néerlandais ? Bah OK, on va leur donner des formations de néerlandais. On va faire des accords avec le VDAB, on va faire des accords avec Brussels Airport,
on va faire des accords avec des partenaires de Brussels Airport ou des entreprises qui sont sur le côté.
En plus, la ligne de bus, elle est déjà là. By the way, c'est une ligne de bus de De Lijn, hein. C'est même pas une ligne de bus de la STIB, même si sur certains tracés, ils sont ensemble.
Et donc tout ça pour dire, non, mais ça peut paraître des détails pratico-pratiques, mais c'est ça qui fait le frein aujourd'hui.
Aujourd'hui, vous êtes un jeune dans un quartier. On vous explique : « Vous allez être discriminé. La société, elle vous en veut.
On n'aime pas les musulmans. » « Ah merde, ça tombe mal, je suis musulman. » Et on vous dit : « Donc, tu vas aller au chômage, on va pas-- t'inquiète pas pour ça.
Y a une assoce qui va t'aider. Tu pourras peut-être même être à la maison de quartier de temps en temps. » Et là, beh, vient aussi, parce que c'est une réalité, vient aussi le fait que,
bah, y a d'autres types d'activités parfois qui peuvent se développer dans le chef de certains, en se disant : « Bah finalement, c'est pas si mal, ça peut être du travail non déclaré.
» Et ça, c'est pas à Molenbeek, hein. Encore une fois, des réalités que je suis en train de vous décrire, elles sont les mêmes à Carnion ou à Colfontaine, avec beaucoup moins de populations immigrées.
Il faut bien comprendre que c'est un enjeu socioéconomique. Ce n'est pas un enjeu par rapport à une nationalité ou à une religion.
Le problème à Bruxelles, c'est qu'on l'a résumé comme tel. Et moi, aujourd'hui, je considère que la vie est tout aussi compliquée si vous vous appelez Mohamed à Molenbeek que si vous vous appelez Kevin à Colfontaine.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose qu'on n'entend pas assez et qui, je pense Comme on a un mauvais diagnostic, on prend pas les bons remèdes.
Et donc encore une fois, je dis pas qu'il y a zéro discrimination en Belgique, mais avant d'arriver à ce motif explicatif, faudrait peut-être déjà résoudre toutes les étapes qu'il y a entre-temps.
Parce que, a contrario, y a quand même, et heureusement, mais on parle jamais d'eux, plein de gens issus de l'immigration
italienne, Afrique du Nord, Afrique noire, et cetera, dans notre pays, avec des gens qui occupent des fonctions à responsabilité.
J'étais-- ben oui, voilà. Mais donc ça veut dire que c'est possible. Alors, est-ce que pour autant, ils ont les mêmes chances que les autres au départ ?
Encore une fois, je vous dis, pas nécessairement, mais pour le moment, on s'attaque pas aux raisons primaires avant de commencer à faire tout un récit qui, à mon sens, est un récit victimaire qui n'aide personne.
Mh, on l'a bien compris que c'était votre position. Partons maintenant sur un sujet tout autre qui serait alors la question du nucléaire.
Beaucoup d'évolutions ces derniers mois, en partie dues à votre lobbying, mais également en partie dues à l'actualité récente et aux relations que nous avons avec la Russie.
Historiquement, y a des discours qui ne s'accordent pas vraiment dans la bouche, que ce soit de la présidence d'Ecolo ou dans les discours plutôt du Parti libéral.
Engie a notamment envoyé une lettre à Charles Michel en 2018 pour prolonger la sortie du nucléaire. Lui, le ministre de l'Énergie MR de l'époque, Marie-Christine Marghem, s'y sont opposés.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez cette incohérence dans les discours ? Puisque on entend que le MR a toujours défendu le nucléaire.
Et puis on retrouve ces sons de cloche un petit peu différents dans l'histoire. Comment est-ce que vous expliquez ça ?
Bah écoutez, les choses sont assez simples. En fait, que s'est-il passé
? C'est que nous étions dans un accord de gouvernement qui, je le rappelle, à l'époque du gouvernement de Charles Michel, a prolongé de 10 ans les centrales nucléaires.
10 ans. Normalement, elles devaient fermer en 2015. Nous entrons au gouvernement en 2014 avec la fonction de Premier ministre et nous prolongeons de 10 ans.
Et à l'époque, pourquoi c'est que 10 ans et pas au-delà ? Parce qu'en fait, y avait quatre partis dans ce gouvernement et y avait un des partis flamands qui ne souhaitait pas qu'on aille au-delà.
Et donc, à partir de là, ben voilà, c'était pas faisable. Donc quand en 2018, ça arrive, le signal qui est renvoyé, c'est de dire : « Ça fera l'objet de la négociation du prochain gouvernement ».
Et c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé. Et donc nous faire porter le chapeau alors que sans nous, y aurait déjà plus de nucléaire depuis 2015, puis sans nous, cette fois-ci, on aurait arrêté le nucléaire en décembre 2020, T1.
Enfin, déjà d'ailleurs en octobre 2020, pour être clair, et après en décembre 2021, et que maintenant, finalement, tout le monde se rallie à l'idée de prolonger.
Donc je suis assez à l'aise par rapport à ça. Après, quand vous dirigez un gouvernement, vous faites des accords. Nous, on savait très bien que on pouvait attendre jusqu'en 2021, 2022, parce que on était dans les délais.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on sait que pour prolonger du nucléaire, il faut donner l'indication 36 mois à l'avance, 30 à 36 mois au plus tard à l'avance, parce qu'il y a des commandes d'uranium et des démarches à mener.
Donc, on était tout à fait dans ces délais.
Dans votre programme, il me semble, pour les élections de 2019, il y avait également plusieurs pages qui indiquaient une sortie définitive du nucléaire, pour cette législature-ci.
Encore une fois, un changement de position assez radical. Comment est-ce que vous l'expliquez ?
Non, pour une raison simple, là aussi, on avait donc le Premier ministre qui, lors de la campagne électorale, a défendu l'accord qui était celui qu'il a mené comme Premier ministre.
Les choses sont assez normales en la matière. Et puis après, au moment de la renégociation, c'est ce qui toujours a été prévu, y a eu une analyse des besoins et sur la base de cette analyse des besoins, il était évident de prendre du nucléaire.
Après, je revendique aussi
le fait qu'il y ait eu un changement de président et que j'ai moi-même procédé à la modification,
d'une partie des opinions au sein du MR, qui n'ont jamais été les plus hostiles au nucléaire, mais qui, effectivement, n'avaient pas nécessairement mené le combat sur ce sujet de façon aussi forte par le passé.
Mais ça, c'est aussi l'intérêt de, 'fin, de changer les personnes qui sont aux responsabilités.
Il est évident que le fait que je n'ai jamais été, et ça, c'est quand même rare en fait, parce que contrairement aux autres présidents de parti, je n'ai jamais été membre d'un gouvernement.
C'est évident que j'ai une liberté en la matière parce que contrairement à d'autres qui doivent faire attention à pas se démentir par rapport à ce qu'ils ont fait par le passé,
le fait d'être à la fois jeune et ne pas avoir été ministre au préalable
me donne une latitude qui est effectivement plus importante.
Parce que moi, vous pouvez chercher jusque demain, d'ailleurs, mes adversaires l'ont fait, il n'y a aucune déclaration où j'ai pris position contre le nucléaire.
De toute façon, je l'aurais pas fait parce que je n'y crois pas. Je ne crois pas qu'on puisse se passer de nucléaire, ni aujourd'hui ni demain.
Mh. Est-ce que vous vous retrouvez dans les positions, par exemple, d'un Jean-Marc Jancovici en France ?
Ça dépend lesquelles hein, parce que je sais qu'il est très décroissant.
Voilà, j'allais vous dire.
Donc voilà, y a--
mais je pense que c'est comme beaucoup de choses dans le débat public. Moi, j'essaie de ne pas stigmatiser une personne en disant : « Voilà, cette personne-là dit ça, donc la personne est disqualifiée.
» Y a une série de propos de Jancovici qui sont extrêmement intéressants. Je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui connaît bien le sujet de l'énergie.
Donc, y a une série de propos où j'adhère, d'autres où j'adhère pas. Et si j'ai l'occasion de le lui dire, ben, on en débattra.
Comme on peut avoir des points de convergence avec Philippe de Feyt, par exemple, et des points de divergence importants avec lui aussi.
Donc voilà, je crois qu'il faut jamais résumer une personne, surtout quand on est un personnage politique ou quelqu'un issu du monde intellectuel, parce qu'une pensée est plus variée que de résumer une personne à une idée.
Mais donc, pour se recentrer sur ce qui vous sépare justement de Jean Jancovici, à savoir la question de la décroissance.
Donc son idée, pour résumer très rapidement, c'est qu'il y a des réserves énergétiques limitées, notamment en ce qui concerne le pétrole, le gaz, et cetera, sur notre planète.
Que donc, par définition, puisque notre système économique est
Un peu, d'après sa vision des choses, la façon dont il analyse notre système économique tourne autour et est vraiment centré sur sa dépense énergétique, puisque les réserves sont amenées à décroître, à baisser, à disparaître même un jour.
Selon lui, la décroissance, ça n'est pas un choix, ça n'est pas une idéologie, c'est juste : ça va arriver quoi, c'est tout.
Mais en fait, Jancovici reprend à son compte avec deux siècles de décalage le propos de Malthus en fait.
C'est une-- Malthus, lui, l'avait plutôt fait sur la base de l'alimentation. Et donc il disait : « Ben voilà, à un moment,
» À l'époque, je crois qu'on n'était même pas un milliard sur la planète. Et à un moment, Malthus dit : « Ben voilà, en fait, y a un nombre limité d'habitants que la planète peut accueillir
compte tenu des espaces disponibles, des espaces cultivables et donc du nombre de nourriture que l'on peut, du volume de nourriture que l'on peut produire sur une année.
» Et en fait, la révolution industrielle a totalement tué Malthus. C'est-à-dire qu'alors que la philosophie malthusienne commençait à prendre un peu d'essor, et la révolution industrielle, et c'est terminé.
Et ici, c'est exactement le même combat. C'est qu'à un moment donné, il y aura d'un côté les tenants du repli sur soi, de l'autre, les tenants du progrès, du savoir, de la technologie.
Et je suis certain que ce sont les deuxièmes qui l'emporteront. Pourquoi
? Parce que l'homme, déjà, a toujours su déployer, dépasser ses limites et a toujours su résoudre ses problèmes, mais surtout parce que vous n'avez pas le choix.
Aujourd'hui, quand vous voyez l'enjeu climatique, c'est un triangle. Si vous prenez juste : faut sauver la planète, alors votre problème est très facile à régler.
Sauf que c'est pas uniquement sauver la planète, c'est sauver la planète, c'est garantir la liberté fondamentale parce qu'on vit dans une démocratie libérale et maintenir la cohésion et la paix sociale.
Aujourd'hui, la décroissance telle que certains l'envisagent, c'est peut-être bien sympathique sur le papier. Je suis sûr qu'il y a plein d'intellectuels qui en raffolent parce qu'ils disent : « C'est vrai, on a trop.
Oh, j'ai 42 pulls. Pourquoi j'en ai 42 ? J'ai déjà fait deux fois le tour du monde. Pourquoi je le referai une troisième ?
» Donc quand on vit comme ça, y a pas de problème avec ça. Mais aujourd'hui, la décroissance, le point très concret, c'est qu'on va avoir des pertes de revenus, des pertes de pouvoir d'achat et des pertes de bien-être.
Or, regardez sur chaque débat politique, les mêmes qui nous disent : « Il faut faire de la décroissance, il faut vivre autrement », sont ceux qui poussent le plus pour qu'on perde pas un euro de pouvoir d'achat.
Exemple, mais paradigmatique, de ce que je suis en train de dire, c'est la crise COVID. Lors du premier confinement, on était là : « Oh, mais c'est sympa.
Finalement, on travaille depuis sa terrasse et on doit moins se déplacer. » Y avait du soleil en plus. À l'époque, on était dans une période un peu sympa.
Et donc tout le monde disait : « Il faut vivre autrement. » OK. Qu'est-ce qu'on a dû faire ? On a dû faire en sorte que personne ne perde un euro.
C'était le quoi qu'il en coûte de Macron, qui était appliqué un peu partout en Europe. Et donc, c'est quoi cette décroissance ?
Donc c'est une décroissance d'activité, mais personne doit perdre un euro. Et donc ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire qu'on le paye sur l'endettement de l'État.
Et donc, à un moment donné, ça se casse la figure parce que la dette de l'État est sur les marchés financiers. Et si un État est attaqué, eh bien, un État tombe en faillite comme le reste et doit couper dans ses services publics.
C'est ce qui est arrivé à la Grèce. Et donc, à un moment donné, ça ne tient juste pas la route, cette idée de décroissance.
La décroissance, pour fonctionner, doit atteindre le consensus social selon lequel chacun réduit. Alors, je sais qu'on va me dire : « Mais non, mais y a des ultra-riches qui ont tellement beaucoup que si juste eux réduisaient, ça irait.
» Mais c'est pas vrai non plus. Aujourd'hui, des personnes plus précarisées vont par exemple acheter, ou pas nécessairement précarisées, la classe moyenne, vont acheter leurs vêtements chez Primark.
Pourquoi ils font ça ? C'est pas moi qui les oblige. Ils font ça parce qu'ils se disent : « Attends, le pull est beaucoup moins cher et avec l'argent que j'ai, je peux partir en voyage.
» Tant que toutes ces personnes, toutes ces personnes veulent continuer à s'acheter des nouveaux pulls et à partir en voyage et à avoir Netflix et de pouvoir travailler à distance avec le dernier Apple qui machin ceci.
Tant que cette aspiration-là existe dans la population, et l'aspiration, elle existe pas parce qu'on bourre le crâne des gens, hein.
Ça, c'est aussi une thèse de gauche qui consiste à dire : le marketing pollue votre esprit. Non, objectivement, c'est juste que c'est plus agréable au mois de juillet d'être au bord d'une piscine en Espagne que de se prendre la grêle à Ostende quoi.
Ça, c'est une réalité. Donc, à un moment donné, si les gens voyagent beaucoup en avion pour du loisir, c'est pas par distraction.
Si aujourd'hui, y a plein de supporters de clubs de foot qui vont parfois juste un week-end pour voir un match de foot en Angleterre ou en Italie, c'est pas parce qu'on les a obligés.
Y a même pas de pub pour ça. C'est juste qu'ils se sont dit : « Bah tiens, c'est pas cher pour aller à Milan. Et comme ça, je vois Milan jouer plutôt que d'aller voir les Francs Borains », dont je suis président.
C'est d'ailleurs un emmerdement pour nos clubs parce qu'il y a moins de gens qui viennent voir le football dans les divisions inférieures en Belgique.
Et donc pourquoi je dis ça ? Parce qu'aujourd'hui,
je n'ai vu aucune femme ou aucun homme politique avoir le courage de se présenter aux élections avec comme élément de programme la décroissance, en expliquant ce qu'est la décroissance dans le concret.
Comment on fait cette décroissance dans la vie quotidienne des gens ? Parce que, et je termine là-dessus, mais c'est un sujet très important.
Je le disais tout à l'heure, moi, je me suis retrouvé devant des industriels, en tout cas des enfants d'industriels hein.
C'était pas eux les industriels, leurs parents étaient un peu plus réalistes, qui me disaient : « Oui, mais la décroissance, c'est bien », et cetera.
Et moi, je lui disais : « Donc vous, vous avez déjà fait le tour du monde. Vous avez certainement une villa quatre façades avec une piscine, mais piscine chauffée via le photovoltaïque, donc c'est pas grave.
Et vous allez m'expliquer à moi qui suis, qui viens d'un milieu très populaire, qui vit toujours dans son appart de 60 mètres carrés.
J'ai pas encore eu l'occasion de trouver autre chose. Et voilà, je m'y pile pas si mal, qui a pas de photovoltaïque, qui a jamais voyagé jusqu'à ses 18 ans.
Eh ben, vous allez me dire à moi que je dois faire moins. Donc maintenant que j'arrive à une capacité où je pourrais avoir un peu plus, eh ben moi, je dois avoir moins parce qu'il y en a d'autres qui se sont goinfrés avant.
» Alors, ma petite personne, on s'en fout. Le problème, c'est que ce raisonnement-là, vous devez le poser aux Chinois, aux Indiens, aux Sud-Américains, aux Africains.
Je sais pas si on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui, en Afrique, on a près de 80 % de la population qui a moins de 35 à 40 ans.
Donc on a une population extrêmement jeune. Qu'est-ce qu'on va aller expliquer à ces gens qui n'auront jamais accès à une télévision, jamais accès à une voiture, jamais accès à un certain confort de vie matériel ?
Tout ça, vous savez pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait, nous, on a fait beaucoup trop de conneries. Donc à un moment, c'est pour ça que notre conclusion, c'est de dire : la solution doit être technologique.
Parce que toute autre forme va engendrer soit des atteintes aux libertés qu'en tant que libéral, on ne peut pas accepter, et c'est même pas ou, et des troubles sociaux qui seront non maîtrisables.
Et la meilleure preuve, si vous en voulez une dernière, qu'est-ce qu'on a dû faire pour les carburants ? Les écolos, ils sont au gouvernement.
Pourtant, ils ont pas pu résister au fait que le diesel était à 2 € à la pompe. Ils ont pas pu résister que les gens n'arrivaient plus à remettre du mazout dans leur chaudière.
Ils ont pas pu résister au fait que le gaz faisait qu'il y a des gens, ouais, on va descendre d'un ou deux degrés la température, mais bon, à partir de 16, 17 degrés, il commence à cailler quand même.
Et donc même eux, avec leurs grandes théories, ils ont pas pu dire aux gens : c'est time. Et donc oui, on v-- et d'ailleurs, eux-mêmes choisissent la réponse technologique.
Ils nous disent le renouvelable. Indépendamment du fait que je ne crois pas au 100 % renouvelable parce que techniquement impossible, mais c'est un choix technologique.
Les éoliennes, les photovoltaïques, c'est du choix technologique, c'est pas de la décroissance.
Donc à un moment donné, vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous voulez, mais quand vous avez les gens qui sont dans la rue qui vous disent : moi, j'arrive plus à finir le mois et je vis plus mal que mes parents
et mes enfants, ils vont vivre plus mal que mes grands-parents.
Ce jour-là, hein, toutes vos grandes idées de décroissance, les grandes idées de décroissance, pas les vôtres.
Oui, je-
Je m'adresse pas à vous. Non, mais je m'adresse pas à vous. C'est parce que je fais comme si j'avais, voilà.
Mais toutes ces grandes idées de décroissance ne tiennent pas plus de cinq minutes. Et les Gilets jaunes, d'ailleurs, étaient aussi une illustration.
Bon alors, de nouveau, énormément de choses qui ont été dites. Je ne vais pas pouvoir répondre sur chaque élément non plus.
Le solutionnisme technologique, c'est effectivement quelque chose qui vous sépare d'un Jean-Marc Jancovici, encore une fois.
J'aimerais transiter, puisque vous parliez donc des différentes populations à travers le monde, que ce soit en Afrique, que ce soit en Chine, en Inde, et cetera.
Une grande conviction libérale que vous avez, c'est effectivement de prôner plutôt une écologie de l'incitation plutôt qu'une écologie de la sanction.
À quoi ressemble une écologie de l'incitation au niveau, justement, de ces populations indiennes, chinoises, africaines ?
Mais donc, par rapport à cet élément, c'est surtout un point qui s'adresse à nos populations, c'est la fiscalité versus l'avantage fiscal, souvent.
Mais au niveau de pays qui sont avec des situations de développement différentes des nôtres, y a déjà des solutions structurelles qui doivent être amenées.
Par exemple, la manière dont on produit l'électricité. Aujourd'hui, on a prévu, on a été sermonner les Indiens sur le fait qu'ils produisaient l'électricité avec du charbon,
mais en Allemagne, ils sont en droit de remettre leurs centrales au charbon en activité.
Donc y a un peu une contradiction. Donc là, y a un vrai travail à faire sur la production d'énergie. Alors pourquoi je suis aussi focalisé sur l'énergie ?
Parce qu'aujourd'hui, l'énergie, c'est 75 % de nos émissions de CO₂. De façon directe ou indirecte, mais quand vous allez vous alimenter, quand vous vous déplacez, quand vous vous chauffez, tout ça, c'est de l'énergie.
Cette énergie à 75 %, le reste, c'est un peu d'industrie, à une quinzaine de pour cent et 10 % l'agriculture. Ça, c'est les grands-- mais le transport est dans l'énergie.
D'accord, oui.
Parce que pour vous déplacer, vous avez besoin avant tout d'énergie. Le reste, c'est rien.
Et donc vraiment, c'est un enjeu fondamental. Et donc dans ces pays, y a vraiment cet aspect-là.
Et donc c'est encore différent que la question de l'incitant ou de la sanction. Là, d'une certaine manière, c'est un avantage, c'est qu'on peut créer un modèle de société dès le départ.
Donc nous, ce qui nous handicape, c'est la transformation qu'on doit mener. C'est-à-dire, aujourd'hui, y a des gens qui ont des chaudières au mazout.
Il faut du jour au lendemain essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils les retirent, qu'ils mettent des pompes à chaleur et que notre production électrique puisse être propre.
Ici, on est dans une série de pays où ça n'existe pas, en fait. Ils ont pas la pompe à chaleur ni le mazout, enfin, je veux dire, installés à la maison.
Et donc, d'une certaine manière, ça veut dire que dans les politiques de développement qui sont faites par ces pays, dans les stratégies, y a véritablement un coup à jouer.
Et d'ailleurs, c'est tout le temps comme ça dans des situations de crise. Des pays qui peuvent parfois être en retard de développement ou des régions peuvent avoir un avantage comparatif, parce que
ils prendront un virage plus tôt que les autres.
Mais aujourd'hui, vous avez parlé de pays qui ont peut-être des situations économiques plus compliquées, mais qui ont, par exemple, des ressources naturelles ou des capacités géologiques ou des capacités aussi en termes de climat.
Hein, vous parliez de pays d'Afrique, ben en matière solaire, y a moyen de faire beaucoup de choses en Afrique.
L'opportunité est là, mais l'incitation, comment est-ce qu'on la trouve ?
Mais l'incitation, elle viendra pas des populations. À un moment donné, ce sont des stratégies qui doivent être mises en place par des gouvernements.
Et là, moi, je suis très prudent par rapport à ça parce qu'en Europe, on a quand même une schizophrénie qui est assez intéressante.
C'est que d'un côté, on dit : il faut pas faire de néocolonialisme, mais de l'autre côté, on n'arrête pas de dire que c'est nous qui devons financer des programmes de développement, et cetera.
Est-ce que je peux juste vous arrêter un instant ?
Ouais.
Comment est-ce que vous définissez le mot schizophrénie ?
La schizophrénie, c'est avoir deux comportements totalement contradictoires.
Ah malheureusement, c'est pas ça. Mais bon, je vous laisserai continuer.
C'est en tout cas schizophrène dans l'acception usuelle.
C'est dans-- oui, voilà, c'est ça, oui.
Mais-
C'est pour ça que je vous ai repris.
C'est l'idée, ou du moins contradictoire, mais c'est l'idée de se dire qu'à un moment donné, si on ne veut pas d'ingérence occidentale dans certains pays,
alors techniquement, il faut aller jusqu'à la suppression de la coopération développement.
Et je vais pas vous cacher-
Vous prônez cette idée-là ou ?
En tous les cas, moi, je considère qu'il y a toute une série de pays qui n'ont pas besoin de coopération développement.
Mh.
Qui, s'ils avaient des dirigeants qui pensent à l'intérêt du pays, je pense, à commencer par le Congo. Le Congo aujourd'hui a tellement de ressources dans son sous-sol qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de coopération.
Le Congo a besoin de dirigeants qui pensent à l'intérêt de leur pays-
Mais donc il y a cette idée de : on conditionne-
Non mais ça, c'est très très important
...pour leur indiquer une direction précise à suivre-
Mais ça moi je-
...au niveau écologique.
Ça moi, je trouve que c'est-
Y a un niveau-
Mais moi je trouve-
...écologique.
Beh, moi, je suis libéral.
Oui.
Le droit des peuples à disposer d'eux-mêmes. C'est quoi cette vision d'Occidentaux où on doit dire à un autre pays : « Tu fais ça et alors on te donne du pognon ».
Encore une fois, ils ont suffisamment de ressources. Alors pas tous les pays. Y a des pays qui n'ont pas de ressources, c'est encore autre chose.
Mais on prend le Congo parce que c'est quand même un pays qui compte dans la coopération développement belge. Moi, j'ai ja-- et d'ailleurs, on a des Congolais qui vivent en Belgique,
qui n'arrêtent pas de-- moi, j'ai déjà eu plusieurs débats, qui n'arrêtent pas de dire : « Faut que vous arrêtiez de vous mêler de la politique congolaise », mais eux, ils font des manifestations à Matongé et à l'avenue Louise,
sur des problèmes qui se passent au Congo.
C'était le cas y a quelques années, encore. Donc à un moment, faut savoir ce qu'on veut. La politique congolaise, elle doit se faire à Kinshasa, elle doit pas se faire à Bruxelles.
Et par rapport à ça, moi, je persiste. Je pense que nos programmes de coopération développement, pour le moment, sont entre deux.
Parce que soit-- en fait, moi, ce que je dis, et c'est ça ma position, soit on fait la ligne jusqu'au bout, c'est-à-dire, on fait de la coopération développement, mais alors on décide comment est utilisé notre argent.
Et donc oui, c'est de l'ingérence, y a une part d'ingérence et on l'assume et on dit : « Bah écoutez, si vous voulez pas de l'ingérence, vous prenez pas le pognon ».
Et alors là, c'est l'autre voie, c'est : on ne fait rien. Et encore une fois, y a toute une série de pays qui sont en mesure de se prendre en charge parce qu'ils ont des ressources qui leur permettent de se prendre en charge.
Ou alors, par exemple, ils ont une population très jeune. L'Afrique a cet atout d'avoir des populations extrêmement jeunes.
Aujourd'hui, y a une série de pays d'Afrique, si vous regardez sur le papier leurs atouts, ils ont des atouts beaucoup plus importants que nos pays, hein, pour affronter l'avenir.
Et donc, c'est cet élément de toujours considérer : c'est des pauvres petits malheureux qu'on devrait aider.
Non, moi, je pense, je suis désolé de le dire aussi brutalement, mais il faudrait plutôt être beaucoup plus dur vis-à-vis de certains de leurs dirigeants qui pensent plus à leur poche qu'à l'intérêt du pays.
Ça, c'est la réalité. Et donc, par rapport à ça, est-ce qu'on-- encore une fois, si on fait des programmes, oui, alors on dirigera le sens de la politique, mais on ne pourra pas nous reprocher tout et son contraire.
Mais celui qui paye décide. Ça, c'est une réalité.
Oui, sujet évidemment très complexe et je n'ai pas l'expertise en diplomatie-
Je peux juste vous dire un truc. Y a un élément sur lequel on pourrait beaucoup plus jouer, c'est l'obtention des visas.
Aujourd'hui, y a des dirigeants qui ont des pratiques et des attitudes qui ne correspondent pas à nos valeurs et dont eux et leur entourage reçoivent pourtant des visas pour venir dépenser de l'argent parfois mal acquis-
Mmh.
...mais aller dépenser cet argent sur les Champs-Élysées à Paris. Là, y a une vraie hypocrisie, dans le chef d'une série de-
C'est un pari donc de dire que en retenant les visas, en ne leur accordant pas les visas pour cet usage touristique,
on espère alors voir des efforts apparaître en termes de politique économique, en termes de politique écologique.
C'est souvent un élément qui fonctionne hein, parce que vous-
Mais vous avez des exemples-
...vous pouvez voir avec le ressortissant russe hein.
Vous avez des exemples de ce genre de chantage, entre guillemets, qui a fonctionné ?
On a eu, avec plusieurs pays africains d'ailleurs, et la France a usé de cette technique à plusieurs moments.
Et aujourd'hui, c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire avec la Russie.
Mmh.
Et donc, est-ce que pour autant, ça va révolutionner le système ? Oui, mais en tout cas, je peux vous dire une chose, c'est que c'est hyper efficace parce que vous pouvez avoir l-
tout l'argent du monde, voilà, la Riviera, c'est quand même sympa, les Champs-Élysées, c'est bien, les grands couturiers, c'est ça voilà, les Ferrari, elles sont toujours fabriquées en Italie, quoi qu'on fasse.
Et donc, à un moment donné, vous savez, l'être humain est assez basique hein. Quand son intérêt personnel est contrarié-
Mmh.
...ça devient un vrai problème. Mais quand vous êtes dirigeant d'un pays où vous ne pensez pas à l'intérêt de votre population,
c'est vrai que votre population ait un plus ou moins d'aide sur place n'est pas l'élément-- tant que vous arrivez à vous maintenir au pouvoir et à les contrôler, c'est pas ce qui vous embête le plus.
Par contre, le jour où vous êtes entravé dans vos plaisirs, ça, je pense effectivement que c'est un langage que certains comprennent plus, en tout cas.
Ouais, ouais. Dans le cas de l'Ukraine et de la Russie, ou plutôt dans le cas de la Russie, certains parlent de guerre économique.
Est-ce que vous êtes en train de dire que finalement, dans le contexte de plus en plus tendu, de
pollution et de, voilà, de crise écologique qu'on connaît à l'échelle mondiale,
on se dirige vers des solutions type guerre économique pour-- c'est aussi une forme de contrainte, alors que vous êtes justement plutôt dans une idée d'incitation.
Quand on parle de priva-- de privation de visas et de contexte, voilà, de guerre économique, pour reprendre cette expression-là, on est un petit peu dans une logique coercitive.
Mais je pense, ça n'a rien à voir avec la question du climat. Ça a question à voir avec la manière dont certains respectent le droit international ou pas. C'est surtout ça.
OK.
Et donc, moi, quand je parle de ça, je vous donne un exemple très simple
: quand des pays n'acceptent pas de signer des conventions de réadmission, les conventions de réadmission, c'est ce qui permet, quand quelqu'un est en situation illégale dans notre pays,
de pouvoir être renvoyé dans son pays d'origine.
Mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire ? Le plus simple, c'est de travailler sur les visas qui sont octroyés aux dirigeants de ces pays.
Je peux vous dire que ça va les faire réfléchir et ça me permettra de rediscuter avec certains qui n'ont plus envie de discuter.
Très bien. C'était donc le sujet du nucléaire. On a commencé en disant : on va rapidement évacuer la question de l'Ukraine, de la Russie et du nucléaire, voilà, pour commencer.
Voilà donc une heure que nous tournons autour de ces deux sujets. Je vais tout doucement transiter vers l'autre question que je voulais aborder, à savoir donc le libéralisme en Belgique, le Parti Libéral qui est le vôtre.
Un bilan intéressant qui est celui de Georges-Louis Bouchez. Une élection, en général, on dit que ça se joue plutôt sur les indécis plutôt que sur le cœur, plutôt que sur la base, hein.
Donc concrètement, ceux qui tweetent en disant : « #fier d'être libéral », on sait, on se doute qu'ils sont plus ou moins acquis à votre cause, mais il y a, voilà, plusieurs segments d'indécis.
On parle notamment régulièrement d'un électorat qui se partage entre Ecolo et le MR. On parle de, voilà, certaines classes socio-économiques
relativement privilégiées, relativement qui ont accès à une certaine éducation de qualité, voilà, loin du stéréotype de l'ouvrier de Charleroi qui appartiendrait, lui, plutôt, de nouveau pour être très schématique,
au Parti socialiste.
Il y a actuellement, à notre époque, une prime à la radicalité. Je pense que vous l'avez bien compris. Être net, être cash dans la façon dont on exprime ses idées.
Est-ce que ces indécis vont être convaincus par cette radicalité ? Est-ce que c'est votre pari ?
Mais en tout cas, vous appelez ça de la radicalité, moi, j'appelle ça une ligne claire, mais voilà, c'est-- je comprends l'analyse.
Oui, c'est plus qu'un pari. C'est que quand une s-- en fait, au début des années 2000, on considérait qu'une élection se gagnait au centre.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on était plutôt dans une période d'opulence, y avait de la croissance et donc on pouvait donner de l'argent pour faire une réforme fiscale et donner de l'argent pour avoir une norme de croissance en soins de santé assez élevée.
Aujourd'hui, on est en période de crise. Donc ça veut dire que tout le monde s'interroge et s'inquiète pour son avenir. Et donc, effectivement, les citoyens sont en recherche d'une ligne claire et de certains caps.
Et donc, j'assume le fait de poser des sujets et de prendre des positions qui soient claires, nettes, par rapport à ces sujets.
Et est-ce que c'est ça qui convainc les indécis ? Oui, bien sûr, dans le sens où, aujourd'hui, vous devez vous rendre identifiable pour que des gens, et moi, c'est ce que je veux, en fait, avec le MR.
Je veux que les gens qui ne votent pas pour nous sachent pourquoi ils votent pas pour nous et que ceux qui votent pour nous soient aussi certains de la raison pour laquelle ils votent pour nous.
Et ça, aujourd'hui,
effectivement, c'est une tâche dans laquelle je me suis engagé. On a été très clair sur la question de la neutralité, du nucléaire, la différenciation des pensions pour les personnes qui ont travaillé et celles qui ont été,
qui ont perçu des allocations sociales,
la baisse des impôts, la différence aussi avec des demandeurs d'emploi s'ils doivent accepter ou non un emploi au bout d'un certain temps.
Et donc, je l'assume totalement, en sachant en plus qu'on est la seule alternative. Et vous devez, dans votre raisonnement, à mon sens, ajouter un dernier paramètre,
c'est qu'aux dernières élections, le Mouvement Réformateur a quand même perdu près de 6 % à sa droite lors des élections à Bruxelles.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose qui n'a jamais été dit. C'est-à-dire que de par nos positionnements, on a permis à des gens
qui ne partagent pas nos valeurs, mais qui se positionnent à la droite de l'échiquier politique, d'aller séduire une série de gens qui, normalement, sont des gens qui votent pour le Mouvement Réformateur.
On parle de partis alors plutôt type N-VA à Bruxelles, plutôt type-
Oui, il y a eu aussi la droite, Parti Populaire, Liste Destexhe, etc. Et donc il y a des outrances qu'on ne partagera jamais.
Pas d'ailleurs chez les trois, hein, parce qu'il faut arrêter aussi de considérer tout sur un pied d'égalité. En tout cas, moi, je ne mènerai pas mon action comme cela.
J'ai des difficultés avec certaines attitudes, mais ça ne veut pas dire que tous les gens qui ont été chez eux sont d'affreuses personnes.
Ce sont des gens qui attendaient une ligne de droite. Mais aujourd'hui, vous nous ajoutez 6 % à Bruxelles, on est largement premier parti.
C'est intéressant parce que vous dites : « Des gens qui attendaient une ligne de droite ». On voit justement une évolution dans la communication du Mouvement Réformateur puisque historiquement, le MR n'était jamais droite.
Et on entend des personnalités comme Denis Ducarme dire : « Mais non, le MR est un parti qui va du centre jusqu'à la droite ».
Et vous, finalement, vous essentialisez le MR en disant : « Non, le MR est un parti de droite avec des réponses de droite ».
Cette évolution-là, est-ce que c'est l'évolution du parti entier ou est-ce que c'est la ligne Bouchez ?
Bah, en tout cas, jusqu'à présent, j'ai pas été démenti sur des lignes de fond.
Et donc, effectivement, quand on veut mieux récompenser le travail, quand on veut la neutralité de l'État, quand on veut une indépendance énergétique, oui, ce sont des lignes de droite qui s'adressent jusqu'au centre.
C'est évident. Notre spectre va de la droite jusqu'au centre. Mais à un moment donné, une position du centre, ça veut dire quoi ?
Non, c'est-- on peut avoir une position de droite qui s'adresse également à un public du centre, mais à un moment donné, la position purement centriste, ben, on a vu ce que ça a donné.
Donc, un peu partout d'ailleurs dans nos démocraties. Regardez la social-démocratie en Italie, regardez en Flandre, en Wallonie, regardez des partis comme l'UDF, par exemple, en France.
Donc, à un moment, voilà, vous-- parce qu'en plus, ce positionnement gauche-droite, on va être très clair aussi-
Oui, bien entendu.
C'est que, ben, c'est un positionnement qui est dû à l'espace politique dans lequel vous fonctionnez. Et donc moi, je suis un sérieux centriste en France.
Quand vous voyez jusqu'où la droite a été, je suis un centriste en France. Aux États-Unis, je suis certainement un peu plus démocrate que républicain.
Et donc en Belgique francophone, parce qu'en Belgique flamande, je suis du côté du centre droit, voilà.
Mais en Belgique francophone, je suis la droite, la droite dure d'ailleurs, aux yeux de certains, tellement il y a des partis de gauche.
Je veux dire, les, en fait, aujourd'hui, les autres partis sont dans un mouchoir de poche entre la gauche extrême, l'extrême gauche, la gauche radicale et la gauche.
Donc oui, c'est clair que dans un paysage comme ça, vous pouvez nous étiqueter à droite. Et moi, quand je le dis, parce que,
à un moment, il faut aussi être clair, hein, moi, je veux bien que certains fassent des thèses de doctorat en sciences politiques.
Je crois que c'est pas le rôle d'une femme ou d'un homme politique,
c'est surtout d'avoir une ligne claire. Est-ce que notre projet est un projet de société qui peut, sur les valeurs essentielles qui déterminent la gauche et la droite, c'est-à-dire la sécurité, la neutralité de l'État,
les enjeux socio-économiques, le positionnement par rapport au rapport à l'État,
est-ce que nous sommes plutôt à droite ?
Est-ce que nous sommes plaçables sur l'échiquier à droite ? Oui, et c'est pas sale. D'ailleurs, vous savez, cette idée, le MR a toujours dit : « Non, mais on est de centre-droite.
» Moi, je dis : « On est de droite et on s'adresse jusqu'au centre droit, effectivement. » Mais de dire qu'on est au centre droit, c'était une manière de s'excuser un peu d'être de droite.
Parce que je sais pas si vous avez remarqué, mais en Belgique francophone, dès qu'on dit la droite décomplexée, ouh, y a-- c'est, on a un peu peur.
Par contre, la gauche décomplexée, ça, c'est cool. Ça, c'est bien, c'est intellectuellement recevable.
Ça dépend qui vous parlez, évidemment.
Oui et non, parce que dans le monde médiatique, en tout cas, c'est ce qu'on constate. On a fait des papiers : « Oh, est-ce que Bouchez met le MR plus à droite ?
La droite radicale ? » D'ailleurs, je vais être très clair avec vous et je devrais pas le faire parce que ça va peut-être amoindrir mes mérites, mais reprenez les discours de Jean Gol,
j'ai encore du chemin avant d'être tout à fait sur la ligne traditionnelle du MR, hein.
Reprenez certains de ses discours. Vous savez, moi, j'ai Julie Morel à la RTBF qui m'a dit : « Vous avez quand même droitisé le parti.
» Très franchement, je l'ai quand même méchamment invitée à relire les discours de Jean Gol. Je pense qu'elle aura quelques surprises en la matière et elle verra que là aussi, je ne suis pas si à droite que ça.
Même si moi, je le revendique et je n'ai pas de problème.
Encore une fois, comme vous le disiez, ça dépend du spectre dans lequel on se place.
Bien sûr.
Si on remonte au XXe siècle, dans ces années-là, c'est sûr que les choses étaient assez différentes.
Donc voilà, on sent dans les mots que vous employez certaines pirouettes pour conserver donc cet électorat, tu vois, du centre jusqu'à la droite, tout en maintenant donc un cap clair qui est plutôt axé vers la droite.
Mais donc, je reviens sur l'idée que je présentais juste avant, c'est-à-dire que si je reprends, par exemple, celui qui était votre opposant, Denis Ducarme,
qui annonce déjà la couleur en indiquant qu'il y aura aux prochaines présidentielles, de nouveau une opposition,
qui viendra de sa part pour présenter une ligne qu'il présente comme étant d'inscription libérale démocrate ou libérale sociale.
Et quand je parle de libérale sociale, je pense évidemment également à votre ancien collègue
Jean-Luc Crucke, qui incarnait cette ligne-là et qui a quitté le Mouvement Réformateur en expliquant que-- enfin, en fait, est-ce qu'il a quitté le parti ou pas ?
En tout cas, il était-
Certainement pas, puisqu'il aura besoin des voix du MR pour devenir juge à la Cour constitutionnelle.
Le parti crasse. Mais le-
Ouais, mais réalité du système.
Pardon, mais donc c'est-
On peut dire qu'on n'est plus en phase avec un parti, mais à un moment, quand on a besoin de ce parti pour être élu-
J'ai fait quelques lapsus, donc, dans mon explication. Mais donc, il a quitté le gouvernement wallon parce qu'il n'était plus en phase avec son parti, comme vous le disiez.
Donc, il y a plusieurs axes, plusieurs familles au sein du Mouvement Réformateur. On se souvient également de votre quote pendant les présidentielles du MR à l'égard de Christine Defraigne, puisque vous expliquez que
elle avait plutôt sa place au Parti socialiste.
Donc des mots assez durs, envers, voilà, donc cette pluralité qu'il y a au sein du Mouvement Réformateur.
Donc pour vous, c'est la droite et on est un parti qui se veut axé vers la droite. Pourtant, je peux trouver facilement, comme je vous le disais, des voix dissonantes à ce niveau-là, qui incarnent un libéralisme plutôt social.
Donc je reviens à ma question-
Justement, dans cette idée-là, est-ce que vous pouvez me dire ce qu'il propose de différent sur un seul sujet par rapport à ce que je propose ?
Parce que ce qui est assez drôle-
Mh
...c'est qu'on essaye de nous dire qu'il y aura un courant libéral social. Mais ce courant libéral social, jusqu'à présent, il ne sait pas me sortir une prise de position que j'ai prise depuis que je suis président-
Non, je prends l'exemple le plus simple
...de différent. C'est-- par exemple, sur le nucléaire, non, sur les pensions, non, sur l'emploi, non. La migration, ça tombait bien pour un mec de droite, j'en ai pas parlé depuis que je suis président, hein.
Donc ça, vous pouvez le vérifier. Je n'ai jamais-- bah, parce que vous m'interrogez là-dessus et je ne l'ai pas instrumentalisé.
J'ai essayé de répondre dans le détail à vos questions, mais je veux dire, je n'ai pas, moi, amené le sujet de immigration zéro, des billets du genre.
Donc sur la sécurité, je pense qu'il y en a aucun dans le parti qui dit que, bon, on pourrait s'en prendre aux policiers sans que ça pose problème, en particulier pas Denis, hein, il faut quand même être clair aussi.
Donc moi, je vais vous dire, le père du libéralisme social, c'est Louis Michel. Louis Michel, qui, à un moment donné, fait passer ce message.
Pourquoi ? Parce que nous sommes isolés dans l'opposition depuis de nombreuses années, après le départ du gouvernement Martens-Gol, voilà.
Et il envoie ce signal. Il dit : « Voilà, nous, on a aussi des éléments », parce que l'image du parti était aussi très différente à l'époque et le contexte.
Je pense que si vous reprenez les dernières interviews de Louis Michel, c'est difficile d'avoir quelqu'un qui est plus supporter de ma présidence que lui.
Et donc, je suis toujours un peu surpris que des gens qui d'ailleurs se découvrent libéraux sociaux avec le temps,
aujourd'hui, soient pris comme référence, alors que celui qui a inventé le libéralisme social, c'est Louis Michel avec Richard Miller.
Et c'est un peu mes deux,
mes deux pères en politique, puisque c'est Louis qui m'a découvert, c'est Richard qui m'a mis sur une liste la première fois, et ce sont des gens avec qui j'étais encore il y a deux soirs et qui soutiennent pleinement mon action. Donc voilà.
Vous êtes étonné, mais on fait le constat d'une pluralité d'opinions au sein du Mouvement Réformateur.
Oui, mais je vais être franc avec vous. Je pense que, comment dirais-je ? Parfois, le fait d'être désigné ou de ne pas être désigné peut changer certaines sensibilités.
Et au surplus, encore une fois, moi, je suis ouvert à toutes les opinions. Vous pouvez demander en interne, contrairement à ce qu'on dit, on organise
énormément de réunions de coordination et d'ailleurs, ça se voit dans notre action.
Et au surplus, je suis prêt à entendre beaucoup de choses. Mais encore une fois, je n'ai toujours pas entendu, et j'ai d'ailleurs posé la même question à des journalistes qui n'ont toujours pas répondu,
je n'ai toujours pas entendu une position où on pourrait dire
: « Eh bien, Georges-Louis Bouchez propose ça.
Or, dans le parti, des gens voudraient qu'il propose l'inverse. » Sur des thématiques concrètes, parce que moi, ce que j'ai entendu jusqu'à présent,
c'est beaucoup de mots, de dire : « Attention, il faut avoir une approche plus-- » OK, si on parle de wording, on n'est plus dans une divergence de ligne politique.
Certains ont peut-être des opinions en matière de communication politique, ils voudraient être consultants en la matière.
Ça, moi, j'ai pas de problème sur le sujet et on a tous notre style. Et c'est vrai que j'ai un style direct. Et parfois, être direct peut être considéré comme brutal pour certains, chose que je ne crois pas être, en tout cas à titre,
à titre personnel, dans mes relations.
Mais encore une fois, le jour où on me sort une idée précise et on me dit : « Voilà la divergence. » Et là-dessus, on voit ce qu'il en est.
Mais c'est très simple. La situation qui a amené à
la démission de Jean-Luc Crucke, qui était donc ce projet de loi qui était considéré donc de mémoire par les parlementaires de-- et donc par le parti, par Georges-Louis Bouchez comme étant,
nuisible à la classe moyenne et donc nuisible à l'électorat du Mouvement Réformateur.
Là, y a une divergence entre son axe et le vôtre.
Oui, mais la différence, c'est pas un axe et le mien, c'est que dans le parti, personne n'a soutenu ce texte. Personne.
Lui.
Lui. Oui, mais donc quand vous êtes le seul-
C'est l'exemple que vous demandiez.
Oui, mais donc OK, mais alors c'est encore différent de la situation de monsieur Ducarme ou de madame Defraigne.
Mais quand vous êtes le seul à défendre une ligne contre l'opinion de tout le parti, c'est peut-être pas le parti qui a changé.
Mmh.
C'est peut-être vous qui avez évolué. Je rappelle que Jean-Luc Crucke était considéré jusqu'en 2014, 2015 comme l'aile droite du MR.
Il a été le premier à dire que nous devions faire un accord avec la N-VA. Il s'est toujours revendiqué comme un disciple de Jean Gol.
Et, encore une fois, je le rappelle, il faut aller relire les discours de Jean Gol et les prises de position de Jean Gol.
Et donc moi, j'ai beaucoup de respect par rapport à ça, hein. Et je pense que Jean-Luc ne nie pas non plus que son expérience de vie l'a amené à peut-être faire évoluer des positions politiques.
Et ça, je l'assume et je pense qu'il a un honneur, c'est de se dire : moi, je ne me sens plus en phase, donc je prends une éch-- voilà, je prends une échappatoire, je fais autre chose.
Plutôt que de faire comme certains parfois, et je ne vise personne en particulier, je préfère être clair, mais on sait que ça existe en politique, de gens qui parfois restent dans des fonctions alors que
ils n'y croient plus eux-mêmes ou ils sont en décalage.
Donc moi, je trouve que c'est sain, ça peut arriver. Ça n'en fait pas une généralité dans le parti. C'est juste ça que je voulais indiquer.
Bon, mais donc on entend, je répète, on entend des sons de cloche différents à ce niveau-là puisque on entendait Denis Ducarme présenter, donc déjà, ce sera quand finalement la prochaine présidentielle du Mouvement réformateur ?
Ah écoutez, ça, normalement, le mandat arrive à échéance dans le courant de l'année 2024. Donc-
OK. Encore quelques années.
...ça sera à ce moment-là.
Est-ce que je peux vous demander si vous avez déjà prévu de représenter un deuxième mandat ?
Ah, je vais être très clair avec vous. Moi, j'occupe une fonction que j'adore.
Mmh.
Et j'aime profondément mon parti. Et donc, on peut jamais préjuger de rien. De toute façon, cette fonction, elle ne m'appartient pas.
C'est la confiance des militants.
Non, non, je veux dire votre candidature sera-
Mais moi, je ne suis pas à la présidence du MR en me disant : ce n'est qu'une fonction de passage. Tant que les autres estimeront que je suis utile et que je suis capable de faire le boulot, j'ai pas de raison de quitter.
Donc, voilà. Après, y a plein de paramètres qui vont entrer en ligne de compte. Y aura le résultat électoral, vous allez être jugé, y aura l'état de santé du parti de façon générale à ce moment-là, le nombre de membres,
la perception des autres, la confiance des autres.
Vous devez travailler avec les autres qui vous font confiance. Et donc, je vais être très franc avec vous. Moi, j'ai pas de plan de carrière.
Je sais pas exactement où je serai.
C'est ce que disent tous les politiciens.
Oui, oui, mais-
Je ne suis pas surpris.
Oui, mais objectivement, moi, c'est assez sincère parce que enfin-
Non mais je-
...c'est même totalement parce que-
J'en doute pas.
...je suis un des rares qui le dit, qui a été jusqu'à perdre un mandat pour défendre ses idées. Donc à Mons, pourquoi la majorité a cassé à l'époque ?
Et on pouvait pas prévoir à l'époque que j'allais devenir président du MR. La majorité a cassé parce que je n'étais pas d'accord avec la façon de faire, et avec les lignes politiques.
Et aujourd'hui, j'ai continué à Mons à tenir une ligne en 2018 face à un Parti socialiste pourtant dominant.
Je savais très bien qu'en défendant cette ligne-là, un accord avec le PS était très compliqué compte tenu de nos divergences de fond, même si moi, j'espère toujours que c'est la démocratie qui l'emporte.
Je suis le plus grand parti hors PS de très loin, mais je vois que la démocratie ne compte pas pour certains. Et donc quand je dis que j'ai pas de plan de carrière,
vous savez, quand je fais la campagne que je fais en 2018, pour justement montrer qu'une alternative est possible, quand on voit le score que je fais,
quand je me retrouve quatrième sur une liste en 2019,
alors que très franchement, je pense que beaucoup s'attendaient à ce que je sois mis un peu plus haut,
que je fais 4 500 voix de plus que ceux qui sont devant moi et que je suis toujours pas élu et je continue malgré tout à jouer le jeu, à me représenter encore à une élection,
bah voilà, je pense que je suis pas le plus vertueux de la bande, mais je pense quand même être assez honnête.
Ça, je crois qu'on peut quand même me laisser d'être sincère quand je vous dis que j'ai pas de plan.
D'ailleurs, le meilleur élément qui prouve que j'ai pas de plan, c'est que je prends quand même un volume de risques qu'on ne m'oblige pas à prendre.
Mmh.
Mais je le fais parce que je crois beaucoup-
Pas prudent dans votre style, oui.
Non, voilà. Et je le fais parce que je crois au projet de société porté par ma formation politique et j'ai une idée assez précise de l'endroit où je veux l'amener.
Mais moi, j'aime mon parti. On a fait beaucoup pour les 175 ans du parti
parce que je trouvais que c'était extrêmement important de mettre en évidence-- vous savez, être président du MR, c'est pas tenir un stand de nougat quoi.
C'est un projet de société avec une histoire qui est importante. Quand on regarde la liste de mes prédécesseurs, c'est quand même des gens qui ont fortement contribué à notre pays.
Et donc c'est une responsabilité particulière. Donc oui, pour moi, c'est une fonction qui est pas une fonction de passage.
C'est une fonction à laquelle je m'investis pleinement. Et donc, oui, je suis bien en tout cas dans cette fonction, donc je n'ai pas de raison de vouloir la quitter.
Très bien. Mais voilà qui est clair. On arrive au bout des 70 minutes qui nous réunissent aujourd'hui.
Avant de se quitter-
Je crois même qu'on a fait un peu plus que 70 minutes.
On est à 1 h 18. Oui, c'est ça. Avant de se quitter, donc, question : j'étais surpris de remarquer, donc, puisque on vous connaît fervent utilisateur de Twitter.
J'étais surpris de voir un retweet de votre part. Est-ce que vous investiguez toujours qui vous retweete ?
Puisque vous avez retweeté y a quelques mois, quelques semaines, comment s'appelle-t-il encore ?
Si vous le savez pas, ça va être compliqué-
Non, mais c'est-à-dire que il est sous pseudo, mais c'est JD. C'est celui qui a été condamné pour 10 mois pour le harcèlement de journalistes y a peu, donc au palais de justice juste là.
Celui-ci se vantait en disant : « Ah ben, tous mes adversaires semblent détester Georges-Louis Bouchez. Donc, je devrais peut-être voter pour Georges-Louis Bouchez.
» Donc cette personne-là qui affiche un soutien envers votre personne, mais vous le retweetez. Ça a choqué pas mal de monde dans la petite sphère médiatique.
C'est quelque chose que vous assumez ? Vous faites attention à ce genre de choses ?
Alors, deux éléments. Un : est-ce que je sais exactement qui c'est ? Non, même si je sais que y en a-
Vous situez qui c'est.
...une série qui ont-- Mais moi, je sais pas, voilà. J'ai deux, trois comptes maintenant où je me dis : « Attends, c'est lui ou c'est un autre ?
» Objectivement, je suis pas-- je suis pas addict là-dessus. Je vérifie simplement qu'effectivement la personne n'affiche pas des convictions extrémistes-
Mmh.
...des éléments de ce type. Pour le reste, je vais être très clair, je ne connais pas le pedigree de toutes les personnes que je retweete.
Donc si ça tombe, vous-même, vous avez retweeté quelqu'un qui a été condamné à une peine de prison sans le savoir. Et par contre, j'aimerais quand même ajouter autre chose-
Oui, dites-moi.
...au risque que ça fasse polémique chez certains. Cette personne, à ce que je sache, bah, je ne connais pas la condamnation, je connais pas l'affaire, je veux pas m'y intéresser.
Bon voilà, moi, je condamne toute forme de
harcèlement. Donc y a pas de difficultés là-dessus, mais toutes les personnes que je rencontre, je vais me mettre clair avec vous, toutes les personnes avec qui je fais des photos, je ne connais pas leur pedigree.
Donc je n'exclus pas qu'un jour, on puisse exhumer une photo avec quelqu'un où on dit : « Ah, Bouchez a fait une photo à côté d'un type.
» Mais vous savez, lors du congrès des 175 ans, je crois que j'ai fait des photos pendant près de quatre heures, hein, avec les gens qui étaient dans la salle, trois, quatre heures.
Voilà, et je vais pas commencer à dire : « Bon, vous, ça va ? Vous avez jamais eu de problème dans la vie ? » Etc, etc.
Donc il faut quand même prendre ça en compte. Et par ailleurs, vous savez, je crois pas que cette personne a été déchue de sa liberté d'expression.
Cette personne n'a pas été déchue non plus de son droit de vote.
C'est plutôt une question d'image, l'image que vous renvoyez, que vous choisissez d'associer à votre-
Encore une fois, ceux qui connaissent ça, c'est ceux qui vraiment sont dedans. Moi, je ne-
C'est Twitter ça en même temps.
...oui, voilà, c'est le petit monde. Et je crois d'ailleurs que ceux qui n'arrêtent pas de se revendiquer de la lutte contre le harcèlement feraient quand même bien attention de ce qu'ils écrivent eux-mêmes.
Mmh.
Parce que j'ai quand même beaucoup de gens qui sont des grands chantres du fait de respecter chacun, etc.
Quand vous voyez ce que je prends tous les jours. Si j'avais dû attaquer en justice, je pense qu'il y en a un ou deux que j'aurais pu faire condamner.
Mais voilà, j'ai fait un autre choix. Chacun réagit-
Mmh.
...comme il l'estime. Et moi, je veux pas m'immiscer dans ces histoires. Je lis beaucoup de choses par rapport à Myriam Leroy, par rapport à Florence Hainaut.
Bon voilà, moi, je pense que la justice doit faire son boulot. Je crois que personne ne doit bien évidemment être attaqué-
On est tout à fait d'accord à ce niveau-là, mais c'est justement la surprise qui est que vous retweetez des articles de Marcel Sel qui sont plutôt-- ben alors évidemment, lui va dire le contraire, mais fantaisistes et plutôt,
de ce qu'il m'apparaît, assez-
En tout cas, je peux vous dire une chose, c'est que tout ce que j'ai retweeté de Marcel Sel-
Ouais.
...je l'assume.
D'accord.
Et donc si on trouve des éléments où on me dit : « Ça, c'était pas vrai, etc », je suis prêt à en discuter.
Mmh.
Mais je suis pas d'accord avec tout ce qu'écrit Marcel Sel. Mais quand je suis d'accord, je le retweete et j'ai pas de difficulté avec ça.
Et je l'assume. Voilà, encore une fois, là aussi, je crois qu'il faut un petit peu prendre du recul, arrêter de juger les personnes, regarder les choses en objectivité.
Moi, vous savez, je me rappelle de l'époque où Florence Hainaut était sur Twitter.
Elle était très dure avec vous.
Elle n'a pas toujours été des plus charmantes. Ça, c'est tout à fait son droit.
Certainement.
Mais elle n'a pas non plus été toujours tout à fait dans les clous, je pense, quand on voit certaines pratiques.
Mais voilà, après, chacun utilise sa liberté d'expression. Moi, ce qui me dérange, c'est que certains estiment pouvoir faire de la police de la pensée.
Ça, c'est quelque chose qui, je pense, ne peut pas être accepté. Donc est-ce que ce que j'ai retweeté de Marcel Sel contient de la diffamation ?
Est-ce que ça contient de la calomnie ? Est-ce que, à un moment donné, ça viole un quelconque élément légal ?
Je sais que Marcel Sel est régulièrement attaqué en justice.
Mmh.
Jusqu'à présent, il n'a jamais été condamné. Donc voilà. Après, si demain, y a un des propos qui est condamné, on verra à ce moment-là.
Mais en tout cas, de tout ce que j'ai retweeté, je n'ai jamais eu le sentiment que c'était des choses qui étaient excessives, irrespectueuses ou contraires à la loi.
Si pas, je ne l'aurais pas fait. Mais vous savez, à travers ce combat, il y a un combat plus large, je pense, par rapport à une-
Idéologique.
Oui, oui, parce qu'en fait, derrière, il y a une vraie idéologie, un vrai modèle de société. Voilà, y a d'un côté, à mon sens, plutôt de la démocratie libérale.
Et c'est un peu les propos aussi de Marcel Sel par rapport à l'islamisme,
par rapport à certains tenants de la cancel culture ou wokisme et d'autres qui sont wokes et le revendiquent ou le revendiquent un peu moins, mais en ont quand même les pratiques et les attitudes, procèdent à la cancel culture.
Parce que que dire alors de ce que subit Marcel Sel ? Parce que c'est ça aussi, hein, la question à se poser.
Et moi, il est très clair que
s'il faut choisir un camp, je choisirai toujours ceux qui sont du côté de la démocratie libérale, parce que j'estime qu'il y a une série de pratiques aujourd'hui sur Twitter qui ne correspondent pas à un modèle
de démocratie libérale où y a des propos qui peuvent plus être tenus, où y a une chape de plomb qu'on essaye de mettre sur certains sujets.
Et ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup plus, c'est pas que ça vit sur Twitter, c'est qu'aujourd'hui, ça vit dans le monde médiatique et ça vit dans le monde universitaire.
Y a des études qui sont faites, où vous voyez, par exemple, aux États-Unis,
y a une étude assez intéressante qui montre que toutes les thématiques wokistes aujourd'hui sont validées en termes de thèmes de thèses et que tout ce qui va un peu en dehors, même des choses qui étaient fausses, hein.
Donc ils ont rentré des fausses études. C'est vraiment une étude intéressante, d'ailleurs, si vous avez l'occasion de la publier, qui montre que même des fausses études sont validées par des comités scientifiques.
Et de l'autre côté, dès que vous avez une thèse un peu différente, ça devient extrêmement dangereux. Il y a un peu-
Est-ce qu'on n'entrerait pas dans le complotisme un petit peu à ce niveau-là, dans le-
Le grand complot du wokisme qui sélectionnerait les idées qui ont pu- Je vais être franc, c'est pas du tout un grand complot.
C'est juste qu'aujourd'hui, il y a un militantisme-
Mh Mh.
...de certaines minorités bruyantes. C'est pas du tout un complot. Il y a des minorités bruyantes structurées dans des assos, structurées justement par des leaders de pensée soi-disant autoproclamés sur les réseaux,
qui vous créent des polémiques avec tout et n'importe quoi et qui donc, à un moment donné,
imposent à toute une partie de la population ou de la communauté scientifique à se tenir le doigt sur la couture et de pas bouger.
Je vous donne un exemple très concret. Bernard Rentier, par exemple. Pas farfelu, Bernard Rentier.
Non, pas.
Mais c'est l'ancien recteur de l'ULg.
D'accord.
Il n'avait pas tout à fait le discours majoritaire en matière de COVID, par exemple. Mais il a été mis au ban. Il a été totalement mis au ban.
Moi, je l'ai reçu, je l'ai écouté. Ça tient la route, ce qu'il raconte.
Intellectuellement, ça mérite d'être débattu. Je dis même pas qu'il a plus raison que Emmanuel André, mais tout ce qui sortait de la ligne Emmanuel André faisait l'objet d'un bashing.
'Fin, à un moment donné, la science, justement, c'est pas la vérité révélée. La science procède de faits, d'un débat et puis d'une série de conclusions sur la base du débat.
Aujourd'hui, les faits, le débat, tout ça, ça n'existe plus. Il y a la conclusion. La conclusion qui-- alors, quand je dis : « Ça n'existe plus », il faut jamais être excessif, mais
ça devient de plus en plus compliqué.
Et je vous donnais l'exemple tout à l'heure. Aujourd'hui, aller défendre l'idée médiatiquement qu'à Molenbeek, on a un tel taux de chômage, pas parce qu'il y a des discriminations, mais essentiellement parce qu'il y a un faible taux de diplomation,
ça, c'est polémique.
C'est sûr que c'est polémique. Vous pouvez pas dire ça. Il y a toute une série de propos sur l'égalité-
Vous pouvez pas dire ça, mais vous venez de le dire. Et personne ne va vous en-
Ah ben, vous allez voir sur Twitter ce que je vais me prendre si vous sortez cette phrase-là. Si vous voulez, on fait le test.
Ça, c'est la démocratie.
Oui, mais c'est-- OK, mais de quelle manière on va me répondre ? On va pas me répondre sur le fond en me démontrant que j'ai tort.
On va dire : « Le MR vit dangereusement à droite. » Tous les jours, je dis ça. Qu'on vire dangereusement à droite, que c'est du trumpisme, qu'on est des menaces pour la démocratie.
Oui, mais j'aimerais juste des réponses sur le fond. Je vous donne encore un autre exemple de trucs, mais qui pour moi, sont totalement délirants et qui passent maintenant en télé sans aucun problème.
Et si vous allez contre ça, c'est super chaud. Y avait quand même ces manifestations à la place Saint-Géry, pardon.
À Saint-Géry pour-- et à Flagey, c'était plutôt à Flagey, pardon, pour, à l'époque des révélations en ce qui concerne des viols au niveau des bars-
Oui, c'est ça. Balance ton bar.
...du côté de l'ULB aussi, etc.
Au cimetière d'Ixelles.
Au cimetière d'Ixelles. Je vais y arriver. Voilà, merci pour votre aide. Au cimetière d'Ixelles. En plus, j'ai étudié au Solbosch, donc je connais bien les lieux.
Quand vous avez une femme qui va à RTL, qui dit : « On va faire des manifs uniquement de femmes parce que les femmes doivent pas se retrouver face à leur agresseur.
» Donc, il y a deux possibilités.
Soit elle considère que les mecs sont tellement des timbrés, ceux qui ont procédé au viol, qu'ils vont se retrouver dans la manif pour dire de... Soit elle considère que tous les hommes sont des agresseurs en puissance.
En laisser dire un truc pareil à la télévision
sans qu'à un moment donné, on lui remette un peu les yeux en face des trous, que déjà, on lui demande d'expliquer son propos, qu'on déconstruise un peu ça et qu'on arrête de considérer que l'homme blanc est le dominant,
qui à chaque fois harcèle, condamne, etc.
Enfin, je veux dire, à un moment, il y a aussi des gens bien et il y a aussi des femmes. Il y a aussi des femmes qui ont aussi des attitudes qui ne sont pas acceptables.
Eh ben ça, aujourd'hui, c'est... ça devient hyper compliqué. Ça ne va pas. Aujourd'hui, en fait, ce qui compte, c'est pas ce que vous dites ni la manière dont vous l'argumentez, c'est l'image que l'on vous colle.
Et selon l'image que l'on vous colle, vous serez du côté des bourreaux ou des victimes. Et avec cette vision victimaire de la société, ça ne va pas.
Ce n'est pas une façon dans laquelle on peut continuer à fonctionner. Encore une fois, elle est contraire à la démocratie libérale.
On a bien compris. Donc encore une fois, une ligne très, je dirais, conservatrice, une ligne-
Mais en quoi c'est conservateur ?
Ben c'est-à-dire que si on observe-
Vous voyez, donc vous jugez le truc. Donc en fait, pour vous, avoir un mouvement qui fait des réunions en non-mixité ou des manifs en non-mixité-
On n'a pas terminé, mais-
Non, mais si, mais c'est conservateur. Mais le qualificatif, il veut dire quelque chose. Mais c'est pas conservateur. Ou alors, si, je vais vous dire mieux que ça.
Si c'est conservateur
de respecter le principe d'une démocratie libérale qui fait qu'il y a une égalité des chances. L'égalité des chances, ça veut pas dire on va taper les hommes blancs comme les rôles des bourreaux et tous les autres seraient des victimes.
Ça, c'est pas l'égalité des chances. Ça, c'est une autre inégalité qui, à un moment donné, renforce les aigreurs et les divisions dans la société.
Si c'est ça être conservateur, OK, alors j'ai vraiment pas de problème. Mais vous savez très bien que c'est pas ça la connotation.
La connotation, ce serait le vieux rabique un peu,
sur ses vieilles valeurs. Moi, je suis désolé. Faire des trucs où on dit : « Les hommes ont pas le droit de s'indigner lors d'une manif sur des atteintes faites aux femmes parce que ce seraient des bourreaux.
» Mais enfin, on est dans quel délire quoi ? C'est pas comme ça qu'on va se créer une société apaisée. Et donc moi, je suis désolé, j'assume le fait que,
c'est pas parce que certains s'autoproclament modernes et progressistes qu'ils n'en sont pas moins les tenants, au contraire, d'une forme d'obscurantisme.
Pour moi, c'est une forme d'obscurantisme.
Quand j'employais le mot conservateur, c'est donc en opposition à ce progressisme-là qui voudrait changer donc la façon dont interagissent les différentes,
différents groupes, les différentes communautés dans notre société, que ce soit, en grand, les femmes.
Vous, vous l'entendez pas, ces revendications-là, vous n'entendez pas cette demande de changement de paradigme.
Et donc c'est pour ça que je parle de conservateur, c'est-à-dire que ces changements-là-
Mais c'est quoi le paradigme qu'on nous propose ?
Mais attendez, moi, je pose des questions hein, je vais pas-
Non mais je comprends.
Je vais certainement pas, je vais certainement pas-
Mais donc, j'entends beaucoup de, et je parle pas de vous hein, mais il y a beaucoup de réflexions où c'est peut-être mes limites intellectuelles qui se,
qui se manifestent, mais dans les faits, ça veut dire quoi ?
En fait, dans les faits, et on l'a vu avec la Commission colonisation à la Chambre, on nous fait des rapports pour nous expliquer que les afrodescendants devraient avoir des droits de sécurité sociale supérieurs
aux autres citoyens, devraient avoir des engagements sans CV, devraient pouvoir jouir d'une certaine discrimination positive au logement, par exemple.
Mais est-ce qu'on croit vraiment qu'on va apaiser la société en recréant des nouvelles inégalités ? Si c'est ça le changement de paradigme, j'avoue que je suis contre.
Parce que la société d'égalité des chances, c'est pas celle de la vengeance.
Ça, c'est la société de la vengeance. C'est : on va d'abord se venger de ce que vous avez fait, vous, d'ailleurs, c'est très relatif parce que tous les Belges étaient pas des colons.
Et en plus, il y en a beaucoup qui étaient pas nés hein, il faut quand même le reconnaître. On a quand même quitté le Congo en 60.
Et de dire : quand on aura fait ça, l'équilibre de la société sera meilleur. Moi, je suis mais paniqué quand je vois les références intellectuelles de certains élus écolos à Bruxelles.
C'est malade. Ce sont des gens qui disent,
eh bien, que par exemple, y a pas d'égalité à avoir, et y a pas de racisme possible à l'égard des Blancs parce que le racisme n'est quelque chose qui n'est pratiqué qu'à l'égard de minorités.
Et donc les Blancs ici, comme ils sont pas minoritaires, eh ben, il peut jamais y avoir de racisme par rapport à eux.
Mais c'est débile, mais c'est profondément débile, en fait-
Écoutez, écoutez, ce serait beaucoup plus intéressant que vous ayez face à vous-
Ça, c'est vrai.
Quelqu'un qui pourrait vous répondre, mais je ne vais pas me transformer en, je ne sais pas, vous parliez du Parti écologiste, je ne vais pas me transformer en coprésident du Parti écologiste pour,
pour vous dire quel programme qu'ils ont là-bas.
Mais donc oui, je vais couper court à ça, parce que vous partez un peu en roue libre sur le wokisme et le-
C'est passionnant.
Certainement, oui. Mais donc voilà, en tout cas, on sent bien donc une ligne, je le disais, ferme, une ligne cash, une... je disais tout à l'heure, il y a un bonus à la... quel est le mot que j'aimerais ?
À la radicalité.
Oui, c'est ça, voilà. Une prime à la radicalité. Donc, on parlait tout à l'heure du fait qu'il y a une série d'indécis, un segment qui hésite entre Écolo et MR.
Très clairement, vous n'êtes pas en train d'essayer d'aller les chercher du côté d'Écolo. Vous voulez les ramener du côté de MR en expliquant que vous êtes très différents, que vous n'avez pas du tout,
de lignes communes en ce qui concerne donc le projet de société que vous défendez.
Et c'est très clair. Je pense que nous avons bien pu illustrer ça pendant ces plus d'une heure et demie, figurez-vous, le temps passe.
Je vous remercie, Georges-Louis Bouchez, pour-
Merci à vous.
cette une heure et demie passée ensemble.
C'est gentil.
Et on se retrouve alors dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.
À bientôt.
Voilà, comme vous avez pu le voir, mon invité est un petit peu parti en roue libre sur la fin. On sent que les sujets que sont le constructivisme et plus généralement ce qu'il appelle entre guillemets la pensée woke, sont des sujets qui
l'irritent véritablement.
Et oui, le but de cette interview n'était pas forcément de donner une plateforme à ses idées, mais surtout de poser ce constat et de parler de ce clash idéologique qui
anime la présidence du Mouvement réformateur et ce qui est quand même
quelque chose qui est intéressant à acter, je pense.
Je me permets aussi une rectification par rapport à ce qui a été dit à un moment donné. Donc, vous savez que je suis ami avec Myriam Leroy, Florence Hainaut.
Donc, je vais évidemment rectifier ce qui a été dit.
Georges-Louis Bouchez explique qu'il assume tout à fait sa démarche de retweeter les articles de Marcel Sel parce que celui-ci n'a jamais été condamné et que donc, a priori hein, c'est qu'a priori, c'est vrai hein, n'est-ce pas ?
Je rappelle qu'en Belgique, la façon dont ça fonctionne, c'est que quand on publie des articles de blog ou des tweets ou peu importe, on est sujet au délit de presse qui est donc très faible, très réduit, dans un carcan très limité,
ce qui protège Marcel Sel de
toute réclamation qu'on pourrait faire à son sujet.
Moi, je n'ai pas de mal à dire que mon opinion, mon constat même, de quand je lis ce qu'il peut écrire, c'est que c'est tout à fait de la calomnie,
et que non, en soutenant, en retweetant Marcel Sel, Georges-Louis Bouchez n'est pas le défendeur de,
de la démocratie et de la liberté d'expression, mais il est au contraire le pourfendeur et l'oppresseur de, voilà, de certaines voix, par exemple féministes, ici à Bruxelles.
Encore désolé pour le son. Si vous découvrez Septante Minutes Avec aujourd'hui, sachez que ce n'est pas comme ça d'habitude.
J'aurai très certainement plein de choses à raconter sur cette interview dans un prochain édito. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
Et n'oubliez pas que je donnerai une formation à la fois en ligne et en présentiel sur la discipline de l'interview dans trois semaines, le 23 avril 2022 à Saint-Gilles.
À très bientôt. Salut !